From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》节目。
Good morning. And it's a--
早上好。今天是一个——
Good morning.
早上好。
--great morning for New Yorkers and a great morning to be in New York City.
——对纽约人来说很棒的早晨，在纽约市度过也是一个很棒的早晨。
We're at a press conference in a park in Harlem for New York's Mayor Adams in April.
我们现在是在哈莱姆区的一个公园里，四月份时任纽约市长亚当斯正在这里召开新闻发布会。
There are two undisputed truths about the Adams administration. Mayor Eric Adams loves his mother. Mayor Eric Adams hates rats.
关于亚当斯政府，有两点是不争的事实。埃里克·亚当斯市长爱他的母亲。埃里克·亚当斯市长痛恨老鼠。
This event was to introduce New Yorkers to their brand new rat czar. This is a position the mayor created, and his job listing called for candidates who were, quote, "highly motivated and somewhat bloodthirsty with a swashbuckling attitude, crafty humor, and general aura of badassery."
这次活动的目的是向纽约市民介绍他们全新的“灭鼠总管”。这是市长设立的一个职位，他在招聘启事中要求候选人“高度积极，甚至有点嗜血，还要有无畏的态度、狡黠的幽默感，并散发出一股硬汉气场”。
New York's mayor is not popular. He's got huge disapproval ratings on crime and homelessness. Fewer than half of all New Yorkers like the way he's doing his job. So when the mayor talks rats, it's with the joy of a dad whose kids don't want any of the dinner he's cooked them, who, finally, at dessert, gets to hand them massive hot fudge sundaes. He's made it a big issue.
纽约市长并不受欢迎。他在犯罪和无家可归问题上的反对率很高。不到一半的纽约人喜欢他的工作表现。所以，当市长谈论老鼠时，那种喜悦就像一个父亲，他的孩子们不想吃他做的晚饭，最后在甜点环节，他终于可以给他们端上巨大的热软糖圣代。他把这变成了一个大问题。
And I hear it all the time. I'm on the trains. I walk in the streets. People stop me and say, we're with you, man. We hate those damn rats. And remember, Julia? Remember when I came out that rat device? I had a rat device. We caught 96 rats around Brooklyn Borough Hall, 96 rats. And there were people that were yelling, oh, you murderer, you murderer. [LAUGHS]
我经常听到这个。我乘地铁，走在街上。人们拦住我说，我们支持你，伙计。我们痛恨那些该死的老鼠。还记得吗，朱莉娅？还记得我拿出那个灭鼠装置的时候吗？我当时有个灭鼠装置。我们在布鲁克林区政厅周围抓到了96只老鼠，96只。当时有人在大喊，哦，你这个杀人犯，你这个杀人犯。[笑声]
This is the kind of cutthroat swagger in a lot of the remarks this day. Next to the podium is a table with all kinds of gear for shooting, poisoning, and trapping rats. Soon, the new rat czar, Kathy Corradi, takes the stage. And if zingers could kill rodents, well, New York's in good hands.
这天大部分发言都带有这种残酷的傲慢气息。讲台旁边放着一张桌子，上面摆满了各种用来射击、毒杀和诱捕老鼠的工具。很快，新任灭鼠总管凯西·科拉迪登场了。如果冷笑话能杀死啮齿动物，好吧，纽约现在有救了。
You'll be seeing a lot of me-- and a lot less rats.
你们会经常见到我——也会少见到很多老鼠。
Woo!
呜！
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Woo!
呜！
I like that quote.
我喜欢那句台词。
[LAUGHS] There's a new sheriff in town. And with your help, we'll send those rats packing.
[笑声] 城里来了个新警长。在你们的帮助下，我们将把那些老鼠赶走。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
Fully keeping with the giddy mood of the day, the rat czar's parents are there, kvelling for reporters and telling the story of how, at 10, their daughter mobilized her entire neighborhood to fight rats, and so, so proud they can't stop themselves from talking over each other in a gush of words.
为了保持当天这种轻快的氛围，灭鼠总管的父母也在现场，他们向记者们炫耀，讲述他们的女儿在10岁时是如何动员整个街区去对抗老鼠的。他们感到无比自豪，以至于激动得语无伦次，争着抢着要说话。
I'll be honest with you, there were so many applicants. But then when she started to get down--
老实跟你说，申请者非常多。但当她开始深入了解时——
Oh, we knew. We knew.
哦，我们早就知道了。我们早就知道了。
--I was like--
——我就觉得——
And she's right for the job.
她完全胜任这份工作。
I said to my wife, I go, I think they're gonna hire her.
我跟我妻子说，我觉得他们会录用她。
She's right for the job.
她就是这块料。
She's got this job.
她拿到了这份工作。
She's smart. She's super smart. She's great with people.
她很聪明。她超级聪明。她很擅长处理人际关系。
She's gonna do a great job.
她会干得很出色的。
The mayor has made it very clear his stance on rats. He hates rats. I hate rats. All New Yorkers hate rats.
市长已经非常明确地表明了他对老鼠的立场。他痛恨老鼠。我痛恨老鼠。所有纽约人都痛恨老鼠。
Wow. That is strong. [LAUGHS]
哇。这语气真强硬。[笑声]
And not true!
而且不是事实！
Nah.
不。
Not true!
不是事实！
Everybody don't hate rats.
并不是每个人都讨厌老鼠。
OK, so we are going to devote our program today to rats and their hold over our cities and our minds. And for some equal time-- we thought this was very important-- to co-host today's coverage, we thought we would reach out to the one group that did not get a turn at the mic at the mayor's press conference. Welcome, you guys. So let me push this mic a little closer to you there on the floor.
好了，今天我们将专门讨论老鼠，以及它们对我们城市和思想的控制。为了公平起见——我们认为这非常重要——我们决定让今天节目的联合主持人加入，我们想到要联系那个在市长新闻发布会上没能拿到麦克风的群体。欢迎你们。来，让我把麦克风往你们地板那边推近一点。
Too far away, hey. Alrighty. 1, 2, 1, 2.
太远了，嘿。好吧。1，2，1，2。
All right, you want to introduce yourselves?
好了，你们想做个自我介绍吗？
Yeah, I'm Reggie.
是的，我是雷吉。
I'm Rachel.
我是瑞秋。
We are rodents. Yeah, we're the rodent class. We are rats.
我们是啮齿动物。对，我们是啮齿类。我们是老鼠。
Can I ask you guys, like, what do you make of this press conference and the mayor appointing a rat czar and announcing rats as his mission? He's going to kill rats.
能不能问问你们，你们怎么看这次新闻发布会，市长任命了一位灭鼠总管，并宣布灭鼠是他的使命？他要消灭老鼠。
Look, if I had made the same budget cuts that that guy was pitching, I'd also be trying to throw a little smoke and mirrors in the air.
听着，如果我是那家伙，砍了那么多预算，我也会想办法制造一点烟雾弹来转移视线。
A little confusion.
一点混乱。
A little confusion, a little bit of--
一点混乱，一点……
A little confusion.
一点混乱。
So you're saying it's just a distraction?
所以你的意思是这只是个幌子？
Of course it's a distraction.
当然是个幌子。
Absolutely.
绝对是。
I mean, look, who's going to--
我的意思是，看，谁会——
Who's going to fight back?
谁会反抗？
Who's going to fight back against that?
谁会反抗那种攻击？
We're easy. We're small.
我们很容易对付。我们很小。
But we're resilient.
但我们很有韧性。
Yeah, we got the numbers. We got the numbers.
是的，我们人多。我们人多势众。
Well, actually, the numbers are interesting. It's actually a real question. Nobody knows how many rats are in New York City. It's 8 million people, but since you guys are like nesting everywhere under the streets and sidewalks, and you're in ancient water pipes and utility pipes and sewers and subway tunnels, the best guess we could find from anybody who's just millions of rats. That's all they can say.
其实，数量问题很有意思。这确实是个真正的问题。没人知道纽约市有多少只老鼠。人口有800万，但因为你们像是在街道和人行道下到处筑巢，你们住在古老的水管、公共设施管道、下水道和地铁隧道里，我们能找到的最好猜测就是数百万只老鼠。他们只能这么说。
Hey, millions so far. [LAUGHS]
嘿，到目前为止是数百万。[笑声]
We're growing every day.
我们每天都在增长。
Well, actually, that's true. People are seeing a lot more rats in New York. Health inspectors are seeing twice as many rats as they saw just a few years ago.
嗯，这倒是真的。人们在纽约看到了更多的老鼠。卫生检查员发现的老鼠数量是几年前的两倍。
And that's what you see. The future's female. The future's rat.
这就是你看到的。未来是女性的。未来是老鼠的。
The future's rat.
未来是老鼠的。
Let's go!
走吧！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Can I ask you guys, do you see anything in the other side's arguments? Do you see anything in why people find you to be a pest and frightening?
我能问问你们吗，你们觉得对方的论点有道理吗？你们明白为什么人们觉得你们是害虫且令人恐惧吗？
All right, every once and again, a kid gets bit. OK.
好吧，偶尔会有个小孩被咬。行吧。
Well, actually, the last year that we have stats for, 100 New Yorkers got bit by rats.
嗯，其实在我们有统计数据的最后一年，有100名纽约人被老鼠咬伤。
Yeah, but how many--
是啊，但是多少——
And you said it's 8 million. What is that? That's nothing.
你说有800万人口。那算什么？那根本不算什么。
That's nothing. How many New Yorkers a year get stabbed, you know? How many New Yorkers a year get hit by cars? How many rats control rent prices in New York? Very few. Very few of us are keeping Manhattan unaffordable. And yet, somehow, oh, rats are evil.
那根本不算什么。每年有多少纽约人被捅伤？你知道吗？每年有多少纽约人被车撞？有多少老鼠控制着纽约的房租价格？很少。很少有我们能让曼哈顿变得让人住不起。然而不知为何，哦，老鼠是邪恶的。
Yeah, well, let me give you guys the human point of view on this, OK? In this new battle that's going on in New York between a growing rat population and a mayor calling for your blood, let me tell you about somebody who's on the front lines of where the new wave of rats has shown up. Her name is Darneice Foster. She lives just a couple of blocks from the park where the mayor's press conference was held. And she saw the commotion and stopped to watch and talked to my coworker, Valerie Kipnis. Told her that she's lived on 138th Street since the '90s. And they never used to have a rat problem until the pandemic.
是啊，好吧，让我告诉你们人类在这个问题上的观点，好吗？在纽约，日益增长的老鼠数量与呼吁要你们命的市长之间展开了这场新的较量，让我给你们讲讲站在新一波老鼠出现前线的人。她叫达妮丝·福斯特。她住在离市长举行新闻发布会的公园仅几个街区远的地方。她看到了骚乱，停下来观看，并和我同事瓦莱丽·基普尼斯谈了谈。她告诉瓦莱丽，她从90年代起就住在这里的138街。直到疫情之前，他们从来没有过老鼠问题。
Rats outside the building, rats in the basement. This is new. I guess nobody was-- everybody was looking the other way or doing something else. And the rats took over. I-- it's very frustrating. Like, garbage collection day is the absolute worst. There's really no safe place because they're running from garbage to garbage to garbage to garbage. Even in the middle of the street, it's not safe because they dart. So you can barely walk, and you just have to hope, pray to God that they're not there. Like, I shake my keys. I make as much noise. [LAUGHS]
建筑外有老鼠，地下室有老鼠。这是新情况。我猜没人——大家都往别处看或做别的事去了。然后老鼠就接管了这里。我……这非常令人沮丧。比如，垃圾收集日绝对是最糟糕的。真的没有安全的地方，因为它们在垃圾堆之间到处乱窜。即使在街中间也不安全，因为它们会猛冲。所以你几乎没法走路，你只能希望、祈祷上帝它们不在那儿。比如，我摇晃钥匙。我发出尽可能大的声音。[笑声]
So Valerie and I headed to her block on garbage pickup day and met up with Darneice before her kids left for school, which is a big operation in her house. Each of her four kids goes to a different school in a different part of the city. She lives on a really pretty block in Harlem that's all townhouses and trees. It was a perfect spring morning. And as we stood there on the sidewalk, yes, even with the sun shining, there in plain day--
所以瓦莱丽和我赶在她孩子上学前去了她所在的街区，并见到了达妮丝。在她家，送孩子上学是一项大工程。她的四个孩子分别在城市不同地方上学。她住在一个非常漂亮的哈莱姆区街区，到处都是联排别墅和树木。那是一个完美的春日早晨。当我们站在人行道上时，是的，即使在阳光普照下，就在光天化日之下——
[CLATTER]
[碰撞声]
Oh, God! Aw, Jesus Christ.
哦，天哪！哎，我的上帝啊。
--a rat.
——一只老鼠。
Yeah, no, I just saw the rat. I don't know where it came from, but it crawled across the top of the green can. I don't know where it went because I kind of froze.
是的，没错了，我刚看到那只老鼠。我不知道它从哪冒出来的，但它爬过了绿色垃圾桶的顶部。我不知道它去哪了，因为我当时僵住了。
I walk over to a big plastic trash bin and look inside.
我走到一个大塑料垃圾桶前往里面看。
[EXCLAIMING]
[惊呼]
There was a rat chewing through a bag.
里面有一只老鼠正在啃一个袋子。
[RUSTLING]
[沙沙声]
That sound was the rat. Darneice says that it's not just a general kind of post-pandemic surge that's led to all the rats on her particular block. The neighborhood has been gentrifying. One house a couple of doors down sold for $2 and 1/2 million. Others aren't far behind. Darneice rents in one of the only apartment buildings on the block. And she says her landlord is trying to drive everybody out of her building to raise the rents. Hot water and heat have gone out for weeks at a time.
那个声音就是老鼠。达妮丝说，她那个街区老鼠的泛滥不仅仅是因为疫情后的普遍激增。这个街区一直在绅士化。几户人家之隔的一栋房子以250万美元的价格售出。其他房子也紧随其后。达妮丝租住在这个街区仅有的公寓楼之一里。她说房东试图把所有人赶出这栋楼以提高租金。热水和暖气已经停了好几周了。
They don't fix anything. They're harassing tenants. They have managed to harass and get half the building. So half of the tenants are gone. And rats are helping their cause because they just want to clear out my building anyway, so.
他们什么都不修。他们骚扰租户。他们已经设法骚扰走了一半的住户。所以有一半租户已经搬走了。而老鼠正在助长他们的气焰，因为反正他们就是想清理我的大楼。
In New York City, rats are just a pawn in the much bigger clash that is New York real estate. We did reach out to the landlord-- his name is Hamad Ali-- to ask him if he's trying to drive out Darneice and the other last tenants in the building and letting rats to fester as part of that. But he didn't return our calls or texts or our emails.
在纽约市，老鼠只是纽约房地产这场更大冲突中的一颗棋子。我们确实联系了房东——他的名字叫哈马德·阿里——问他是否试图驱逐达妮丝和楼里最后的租户，并任由老鼠滋生来达成目的。但他没有回复我们的电话、短信或电子邮件。
I'm really stubborn. I do not want my landlord to win. Oh, my God! Sorry. Sorry. I'm so sorry. That was humongous.
我很倔。我不想让我的房东赢。哦，天哪！抱歉。抱歉。实在抱歉。那个东西巨大无比。
When rats scamper by, they seem to completely unnerve Darneice. And she urges me and her sons to move away from a stairwell where she's seen rats. There are certain spots where she doesn't like to stand. But her kids are totally unruffled. Her sons, Micah and Amir, they're 9 and 12, both perfectly happy to be late for school to talk rats. Each new rat we see, they're like, yeah, sure. Whatever.
当老鼠跑过时，它们似乎完全让达妮丝感到不安。她催促我和她的儿子们离开她看到过老鼠的楼梯间。有些地方她不喜欢站。但她的孩子们完全没被影响。她的儿子们，迈卡和阿米尔，分别是9岁和12岁，他们完全乐意为了谈论老鼠而上学迟到。我们看到的每只新老鼠，他们都觉得，噢，行啊，没问题。随便吧。
This one looks like it died recently.
这只看起来像是刚死的。
The boys spot this one up the block and show Valerie.
男孩们发现了这只，并指给瓦莱丽看。
Wait, how can you tell?
等等，你怎么看出来的？
Because it's a body. Their eyes are still open, and its body is still kind-- it kind of looks like it's fake playing dead.
因为它是个尸体。它们的眼睛还睁着，身体还在……它看起来像是假装在装死。
And because ants haven't swarmed that place yet.
而且是因为蚂蚁还没涌到那个地方去。
Well, I'm gonna take a quick picture.
好了，我要拍张快照。
Do you feel like the rats have gotten into your head?
你觉得这些老鼠让你心烦意乱了吗？
Oh, yeah, no, absolutely. I am thinking about them a lot.
哦，是的，不，绝对是。我一直在想它们。
I mean, it's just so strange because they're so small, and yet they can loom so large.
我的意思是，这真的很奇怪，因为它们那么小，却显得如此巨大。
They're huge. These are not small rats. [LAUGHS] These are big, fat, jolly rats. They are eating good here. Like, I'm amazed at how agile they are.
它们太大了。这些不是小老鼠。[笑声] 这些是肥硕、快乐的老鼠。它们在这儿吃得很好。就像，我很惊讶它们竟然这么敏捷。
I told Darneice how a scientist I talked to said that the big problem with rats these days is not that they spread disease. She said it's rare in North America for anybody to report catching a disease from a rat. And it's much more common for rats to catch our diseases from us, going through our stuff. Like, New York rats got COVID from us. And the scientist told me that the bigger problem with rats is the very thing that Darneice is experiencing-- the stress, feeling of everything being out of control when rats are there.
我告诉达妮丝，我采访过的一位科学家说，现在老鼠最大的问题不是它们传播疾病。她说在北美，很少有人报告说从老鼠身上感染了疾病。反而是老鼠更容易从我们这里感染疾病，通过翻找我们的东西。比如，纽约的老鼠就从我们这里感染了新冠。那位科学家告诉我，老鼠更大的问题正是达妮丝正在经历的——压力，当老鼠出现时，那种一切都失控的感觉。
It just freaks people out. Like, there's just something about having them around that just gets to us psychologically.
这只会让人们抓狂。就像，有它们在周围，在心理上会影响我们。
It means that you've done something terribly wrong in your life, and you should correct it if you're encountering rats like this. It's like a problem sign. It's like stop, change, do something different.
这意味着你的生活中肯定出了什么严重的问题，如果你遇到了这样的老鼠，你应该纠正它。这像是一个问题标志。就像停止、改变、做点不同的事情。
Well, today, on our program, rats. When rats show up, it is all about the rats. You can't think of anything else. If you have had a run-in with a rat, you pretty much remember it the rest of your life. Today, we let ourselves get transfixed. Why do they get to us so much? Like I said earlier, my co-hosts for the hour today are Reggie and Rachel, New York City rats. You guys have anything you want to say about Darneice's situation? You think she's wrong to be scared?
嗯，今天，在我们的节目中，我们要讲老鼠。当老鼠出现时，一切都围绕着老鼠。你无法思考其他任何事情。如果你和老鼠有过冲突，你基本上会记一辈子。今天，让我们自己陷入痴迷。为什么它们对我们影响这么大？正如我之前所说，今天节目的联合主持人是雷吉和瑞秋，纽约市的老鼠。你们有什么想对达妮丝的情况说的吗？你们觉得她害怕有错吗？
No, no, she's speaking the truth.
不，不，她说的是实话。
Yeah, yeah, yes, it's scary. But you know what? I think the fact that we're being blamed for being a bunch of Beyonces is outrageous, right? When we step in the room, all eyes on us.
是啊，是的，这很可怕。但你知道吗？我觉得我们被指责为一群“碧昂丝”是很离谱的，对吧？当我们走进房间，所有目光都在我们身上。
Yeah.
是的。
All eyes. We're special.
所有目光。我们很特别。
Woo! Buzz.
呜！嗡嗡声。
Right? You know?
对吧？你知道吗？
Valid. Excuse us for shining. Sorry.
有道理。请原谅我们光芒万丈。抱歉。
Rats, you may think you know them. You may think you have nothing to learn. We have stories today I think will open your eyes. Stay with us.
老鼠，你可能以为你了解它们。你可能以为没什么可学的。我们今天的故事我想会让你大开眼界。请继续收听。
OK, so we're going to start today's show with the story that you guys commissioned as our co-hosts today.
好了，我们要以你们作为联合主持人提议的故事开始今天的节目。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Yep, because there's the lie, and there's the rat truth. That's why we're here, to tell our story.
没错，因为有谎言，也有关于老鼠的真相。这就是我们为什么在这儿，为了讲述我们的故事。
Which is why we got this next story for you.
这就是为什么我们为你们准备了下一个故事。
Act 1, Fifty First Rats. So this might be hard for some of you close-minded folks to believe, but there are a lot of people out here who love rats.
第一幕，五十只老鼠。所以对于你们中一些思想封闭的人来说，这可能很难相信，但外面有很多人爱老鼠。
Love us to death.
爱死我们了。
Who see us for who we really are.
看清了我们真实模样的人。
For more, we go to NPR's Elna Baker.
想了解更多，我们去找美国国家公共广播电台的埃尔娜·贝克。
Actually, she's not with NPR.
其实，她不是美国国家公共广播电台的。
Oh, my god. Copy that. For more on this, we go to our very own Elna Baker.
哦，天哪。收到。想了解更多，我们去找我们自己的埃尔娜·贝克。
Hi. OK, so I want to start from the beginning. You and I, we met at a party, right?
嗨。好吧，我想从头说起。你和我，我们在一个派对上认识的，对吧？
Yep.
没错。
You came up to me, and you basically did this thing where you were like, uh, hey, you're a woman. Can I get your opinion on something? And then you explained your predicament. Will you explain for us now what's your current big dilemma?
你走到我面前，基本上做了那种事，比如，呃，嘿，你是女性。我能听听你对某件事的看法吗？然后你解释了你的困境。你现在能为我们解释一下你目前最大的困境是什么吗？
Yes, I have several pet rats. And I also am single and used to be very active dating in the dating scene. And I have to either get rid of my rats, so that I can start dating again, or I guess, become a weird lonely rat person for the rest of my life? I don't know if that's like-- it seems like those are the two options. And the fact that I'm weighing that decision is probably not a good sign. That should be a pretty easy choice. I would think that a couple of years ago, it would have been an easy choice for me, but all of a sudden, it's not.
是的，我有几只宠物鼠。而且我也单身，以前在约会圈非常活跃。我必须要么处理掉我的老鼠，这样我才能开始约会，要么……我猜，余生就做一个怪异、孤独的老鼠人？我不知道那是否……看起来这就是两个选项。而我正在权衡这个决定这一事实本身可能就不是个好兆头。那应该是个相当容易的选择。我想几年前，对我来说这会是个容易的选择，但突然之间，它不是了。
And at the party, you turned to me after explaining all of this. And you said, is me being a rat guy a deal breaker?
在派对上，你解释完这一切后转向我。你说，我是一个养鼠男，这是个交易破坏者吗？
[LAUGHS] And you emphatically said yes.
[笑声] 而你明确地说是。
Yes, because it's not just that Todd has rats. That's his name, by the way-- Todd. He has 12. They roam free all day, and they've taken over his living room, where he's set up an American gladiator-style obstacle course with tiny ropes for the rats to swing from furniture. If this were a Disney movie, it'd be magical. But if Todd were your Tinder date, you'd report his profile.
是的，因为不仅仅是托德有老鼠。顺便说一句，他叫托德。他有12只。它们整天自由漫步，已经占据了他的客厅，他在那儿设置了一个美国角斗士风格的障碍训练场，有小绳子让老鼠从家具上荡过来。如果这是一部迪士尼电影，那会很神奇。但如果托德是你的Tinder约会对象，你会举报他的个人资料。
A little about Todd-- he's 39, a writer living in LA. He's tall, attractive. Says he wants to find a real relationship and settle down. According to his friends, he's really broken up over this choice, constantly telling them he's going to get rid of the rats, but unable to pull the trigger. He's truly at a crossroads.
简单介绍一下托德——他39岁，住在洛杉矶的作家。他高个子，有吸引力。说他想寻找一段真正的关系并安定下来。据他的朋友说，他对这个选择感到非常痛苦，不停地告诉他们他会处理掉这些老鼠，但却下不了手。他真的处在十字路口。
Obviously, I have a strong bias for which road I think he should take, the kind of road that when you're walking, a rat doesn't suddenly come scurrying out, brushing against your feet. And the only thing I didn't understand-- why was this so hard for him?
显然，我对我认为他应该走哪条路有强烈的偏见，那种当你走在路上，不会突然有一只老鼠跑出来蹭到你脚上的路。我唯一不理解的是——为什么这对他来说这么难？
OK, so just help me. Walk me through it. So how did it start with the rats?
好的，帮帮我。引导我梳理一下。那么，养鼠是怎么开始的？
I think that the rats, in a weird way-- I think everybody has at least one weird thing that they got into during the pandemic. For some people, it was like knitting or a weird Japanese TV show. For me, it was having a bunch of pet rats.
我觉得老鼠，以一种奇怪的方式……我觉得每个人在疫情期间都沉迷过至少一件奇怪的事情。对有些人来说，是编织或者奇怪的日本电视节目。对我来说，是养了一堆宠物鼠。
Wait, so I see. So basically, you're saying this decision could only have happened during the pandemic.
等等，我明白了。所以基本上，你是说这个决定只能发生在疫情期间。
100%. Before the pandemic, I was not what you would call a rat person. I spent 10 years living in New York. I thought rats were pests, not pets. Like, they are slightly above or below bedbugs, I guess, on the New York Things You Don't Ever Want in Your Apartment list.
100%。疫情前，我绝不会被称为养鼠人。我在纽约生活了10年。我认为老鼠是害虫，不是宠物。就像，在纽约那些你永远不想在公寓里看到的东西名单上，它们仅仅位于臭虫之上或之下，我猜。
It was probably three weeks into the first lockdown. I was going on a walk, and when I got home in the parking lot to my apartment, I saw this little, tiny, cute, little rat, and he was crawling. And it wasn't like scampering away. He was crawling, and his back legs weren't working. He was kind of like dragging his body with his front little arms. It almost looked like out of Saving Private Ryan, just like a wounded soldier trying to carry himself to safety.
那可能是在第一次封城的第三周。我正在散步，当我回到公寓的停车场时，我看到了这只小小的、可爱的、小小的老鼠，它在爬行。它不像是在逃跑。它在爬行，后腿没法动。它像是用前肢拖着身体。看起来几乎像是《拯救大兵瑞恩》里的场景，就像一个受伤的士兵试图把自己挪到安全地带。
And I felt so bad. It was like one of the saddest things I'd ever seen, combined with also being super lonely in lockdown and just going on a super introspective walk. And I was like, I'm going to save this rat. I'm going to bring this rat upstairs. I'm going to nurse it back to health.
我感到非常难过。那是我见过的最悲伤的事情之一，再加上在封城期间超级孤独，而且刚刚进行了一次超级内省的散步。我就想，我要救这只老鼠。我要把这只老鼠带上楼。我要把它护理回健康状态。
Todd put on a pair of gloves, picked up the rat, put it in a box, did the ickey dance, then went upstairs.
托德戴上一副手套，捡起老鼠，放进一个盒子里，跳了一段“恶心舞”，然后上楼了。
The first thing that happened is I called the Humane Society because I was like, I'll take care of this rat until they can take him in, thinking I would do that the next morning. And they were like-- immediately, the girl on the phone was like, yeah, we don't do anything with rats. I can call animal control to get rid of it if you want, but we don't do anything for rats.
发生的第一件事是我给动物保护协会打了电话，因为我想，我会照顾这只老鼠，直到他们能接收它，想着第二天早上我就能做这件事。他们说……电话那头的女孩立即说，是的，我们不处理老鼠。如果你想的话我可以叫动物管制部门来处理，但我们不对老鼠做任何事。
Wait, the Humane Society is like, uh, ew, no rats.
等等，动物保护协会就像，呃，呕，不要老鼠。
Yeah, at least the one in LA, yeah, they are not very humane.
是的，至少在洛杉矶的那家，是的，它们不是很人性化。
The woman was humane enough to give him the number of a rat rescue. He calls and talks to a woman named Shannon, who says she'd love to take his rats. But she can't for 10 days because she's out of town.
那个女人足够人性化，给了他一个老鼠救援机构的电话。他打电话并与一个名叫香农的女人交谈，她说她很乐意收养他的老鼠。但她10天内不能去，因为她不在城里。
She's like, can you handle it till then and keep it? I was like, yeah, of course, I can, knowing nothing about rats or anything. But I was like, awesome. We've got a project now. Let's do it.
她说，你能在那之前处理它并留着它吗？我说，是的，当然可以，虽然我对老鼠一无所知。但我当时想，太棒了。我们现在有个项目了。开始干吧。
Because of the pandemic, Todd had lost his job. He spent most days sitting at home with his wheels spinning. So Project Keep Rat Alive Until Shannon Gets Home became his new focus. Todd was in luck, though. The rat he took home wasn't a street rat. It was a discarded pet rat. While they're the same species, the difference between street rats and pet rats is similar to wolves versus dogs.
因为疫情，托德丢了工作。他大部分时间都呆在家里，无所事事。所以，“保持老鼠存活直到香农回来”成了他的新重心。不过，托德很幸运。他带回家的那只老鼠不是街头老鼠。它是一只被遗弃的宠物鼠。虽然它们是同一个物种，但街头老鼠和宠物鼠的区别类似于狼和狗。
Still, the first night did not go well. Todd was afraid of the rat, and it seemed afraid of him. It escaped the cardboard box it was in multiple times. But quickly, Todd went from being grossed out to engrossed. He'd google, why does my rat do this, and lose himself for hours reading all sorts of rat behavioral studies.
不过，第一晚过得并不好。托德害怕那只老鼠，它似乎也害怕他。它多次从装它的纸盒子里逃出来。但很快，托德从感到恶心变成了入迷。他会谷歌搜索，“为什么我的老鼠会这样做”，然后花几个小时阅读各种关于老鼠行为的研究。
Also, every pet rat is different because they all have different personalities, much like people. And so you'll go on the Rat Reddit, or Raddit, as it's called, and to Google to look up--
而且，每只宠物鼠都是不同的，因为它们都有不同的个性，就像人一样。所以你会上老鼠Reddit，或者叫Raddit，然后谷歌搜索查看……
Wait, it's called the Raddit?
等等，它叫Raddit？
It's called Raddit. They've got a good one. They locked that down pretty good. It was a real crash course into learning about everything about rats. You have to get it a buddy. Basically, they hate being alone. They get lonely and depressed. And so immediately, I was like, OK, I got to get it another rat for like 10 days, or at this point, it was like 8. And so I went on Craigslist and started looking up rats for sale. So I found a guy who was selling rats for like $3 apiece.
它叫Raddit。他们有一个很好的社区。他们把那里维护得很好。这真的是一门速成课，学习关于老鼠的一切。你必须给它找个伙伴。基本上，它们讨厌孤独。它们会感到孤独和抑郁。所以立刻，我就想，好吧，我得在10天，或者那时候是8天，给它找另一只老鼠。所以我上了Craigslist，开始寻找待售的老鼠。然后我找到了一个卖老鼠的人，大概3美元一只。
And I went to that dude's house, and he's like, OK, here's the two rats I have. Which one do you want? And there's two little cute rats in a little fish tank thing. And I was like, I don't care. Which one do you not want? And he's like, well, it doesn't matter to me. I'm just going to feed the other one to my snake. And I was like, well, now I don't want the other rat's blood on my hands. I'll just buy them both.
然后我去了那家伙家，他说，好吧，这是我有的两只老鼠。你想要哪只？然后在一个小鱼缸里有两只可爱的小老鼠。我说，我不在乎。哪只你不想要？他说，嗯，对我来说没关系。我正要把另一只喂给我的蛇。我说，好吧，现在我不想手上沾上另一只老鼠的血。我把它们俩都买了。
So at that point, I had three rats. And obviously, very quickly, I was becoming like-- they were definitely my best friends and my only friends because, again, it was lockdown. And so, at the point that this lady Shannon got back from visiting her family and was ready to take the original rat in to her rodent rescue, I no longer wanted to give him up. And in fact, she was not surprised that my rat culture had already multiplied to three. She's like, that's how it happens. And then I was like, no way. She's like, yeah, I--
所以当时，我有三只老鼠。显然，很快，我就变得……它们绝对是我最好的朋友，也是我唯一的朋友，因为，再次强调，那是封城期间。所以，当这位香农女士从拜访家人回来并准备把最初那只老鼠带到她的啮齿动物救援中心时，我已经不想放弃它了。事实上，她对我的老鼠文化已经增长到三只并不感到惊讶。她说，事情就是这样发生的。然后我说，不会吧。她说，是的，我……
Wait, she literally says, that's how it happens?
等等，她真的说，事情就是这样发生的？
Oh, yeah. She was laughing. She was like, yeah, that's literally every rat owner. You start with one, and then all of a sudden, you have a ton.
哦，是的。她在笑。她说，是的，那真的是每个养鼠人的情况。你从一只开始，然后突然之间，你就有一大堆了。
She tells him about another rodent rescue where he can get even more rats. Todd says--
她告诉他另一个啮齿动物救援机构，他可以在那里获得更多老鼠。托德说——
I think I'm OK with three, Shannon. Thanks a lot. I hang up the phone, immediately go on Instagram, look at the South Bay Rodent Rescue, and later that day, I had two more rats. I was up to five. And I'm pretty sure-- I want to say later that week, we got to eight. Like, if you added up all the rats I've had between the ones that have died and the ones that got fostered, I feel like I probably had 35 rats at this point, which is pretty insane.
我想三只就够了，香农。非常感谢。我挂了电话，立刻上Instagram，查看南湾啮齿动物救援中心，那天晚些时候，我就有了另外两只老鼠。我增加到了五只。而且我很确定……我想说那天晚些时候，我们达到了八只。就像，如果你把我在已经死掉的和寄养出去的之间拥有过的所有老鼠加起来，我觉得我当时可能有35只老鼠了，这太疯狂了。
35 rats?
35只老鼠？
Actually, it was 37. There's Claude, Pearl, Arthur, Marceaux, Birdi, Lucy, Henry, Bobby, Caesar, Leonard, Oliver, Harriet, Luke, Amanda, Julian, Roger, Ricky, Bo, Penelope, Sweet Lou, Dave, Kelsey, Alonzo, Ebenezer, Eddie, Beth, Sven, Ozmo, Jake, Delilah, Klaus, Alasdair, Eleanor, Gertie, Joshua, Heidi, and Peter.
其实是37只。有克劳德、珀尔、亚瑟、马索、伯迪、露西、亨利、鲍比、凯撒、伦纳德、奥利弗、哈丽特、卢克、阿曼达、朱利安、罗杰、里基、博、佩内洛普、甜露、戴夫、凯尔西、阿隆佐、埃比尼泽、埃迪、贝丝、斯文、奥兹莫、杰克、黛莱拉、克劳斯、阿拉斯代尔、埃莉诺、格蒂、约书亚、海蒂和彼得。
He didn't have them all at once. Rats only live a few years. So the most he's ever had at one time was 14. When I've told friends about Todd's rats, they've asked me, is he OK? Like, is he having a breakdown or anything? And the answer is, emphatically, no, he's fine. But he'd just lost his job, and he was having a hard time getting motivated to find another one in the pandemic job market. And besides, how could he? He was so busy falling in love with rats.
他不是一次拥有全部。老鼠只活几年。所以他一次拥有最多的是14只。当我告诉朋友关于托德的老鼠时，他们问我，他还好吗？就像，他是不是崩溃了还是怎么着？答案是，强调一下，不，他很好。但他刚丢了工作，在疫情就业市场里很难有动力去寻找下一份工作。再说，他怎么能呢？他太忙于爱上老鼠了。
I see rats as vermin, carriers of disease. Just thinking of them skeeves me out. But Todd says, I just don't know them. Like a proud parent, he told me things about rats that converted him. And I got to say, I actually had no idea how intelligent these animals could be. That's part of what hooked Todd. He observed--
我看老鼠就是害虫，疾病携带者。光是想到它们就让我恶心。但托德说，我只是不了解它们。像个骄傲的父母，他告诉了我一些让我改变看法的事情。我不得不说，我真的不知道这些动物竟然可以如此聪明。这就是吸引托德的部分原因。他观察到——
Rats are like obsessed with what we know about what they know. They never want us to know what they know. There's the mind game level. It's like CIA-level mind games of like, they want to keep us in the dark about whatever information they have or whatever they know how to do. So they're very secretive. They love hiding stuff and stashing stuff. And they never want to be caught doing anything naughty, right?
老鼠像是着迷于我们知道什么，关于它们知道什么。它们从来不想让我们知道它们知道什么。那是心理游戏级别。就像中情局级别的心理游戏，它们想让我们对它们拥有的任何信息或它们知道怎么做的任何事情蒙在鼓里。所以它们非常隐秘。它们喜欢藏东西。它们从不想被抓到在做坏事，对吧？
In the beginning, Todd would give his rats treats, which they'd take and stash in hiding spots all over his apartment. Every night, he'd have to clean 20 to 25 little stashes. Todd started to get suspicious. He was giving them treats, but not this many treats. So he set up a GoPro facing the treat drawer to find out what was happening.
刚开始，托德会给老鼠零食，它们会拿走并藏在他公寓的各个角落。每天晚上，他都得清理20到25个小储藏点。托德开始起疑了。他给了它们零食，但没有这么多。所以他架设了一个面对零食抽屉的GoPro，想查明发生了什么。
Sure enough, the rats had figured out how to open the treat drawer by standing underneath it and pushing it open as a team. They'd steal treats, then close it shut. Todd immediately moved the treats up to the middle door. The next day he came into the kitchen, the middle drawer was open, and all the treats were gone. He reviewed the GoPro footage to try to figure out what happened.
果不其然，老鼠们已经想出了如何通过站在下面团队协作把零食抽屉推开。它们会偷走零食，然后关上它。托德立即把零食移到了中间抽屉。第二天他走进厨房，中间抽屉是开着的，所有的零食都没了。他查看了GoPro的录像，想弄清楚发生了什么。
Come to find out that three of them had figured out that if they wedged-- so the oven is next to this cabinet. If they wedged themselves against the oven, with their little tiny fingers, they were able to kind of just wedge in between the drawer and get it out just enough that then they could stick their face in, use their face to wedge it out more. And then all of a sudden, they were able to climb into this middle drawer and start stealing food again. But then, they figured out that they can't close the second drawer because there's no way to push it close. They'd been closing the bottom door.
结果发现，其中三只已经发现，如果它们楔入……烤箱就在这个柜子旁边。如果它们把自己楔在烤箱边上，用它们小小的手指，它们能够某种程度上把抽屉楔出来，稍微出来一点，然后它们就能把脸伸进去，用脸把抽屉撑开更多。然后突然之间，它们就能爬进这个中间抽屉开始偷吃食物了。但后来，它们发现它们不能关上第二个抽屉，因为没法把它推回去。它们一直关的是底下的门。
Oh, and if it's not closed, then that means they're caught.
哦，如果它没关上，那意味着它们被发现了。
Now you're totally caught. So then I don't know what little rat meeting they had, but they somehow came up with the idea that instead of getting caught with the second drawer open and that they had been stealing food, they would take all of the food and treats from the second drawer and put it back into the first drawer, the bottom drawer. So then hopefully, when I would find it, I would think that they were like helping me put it back in the correct drawer.
现在你彻底被发现了。所以我不不知道它们开了什么老鼠会议，但它们以某种方式想出了个主意，与其因为第二个抽屉开着而被发现偷了食物，不如把第二个抽屉里的所有食物和零食拿出来放回第一个抽屉，也就是底下的抽屉。这样希望等我发现的时候，我会认为它们是在帮我把它放回正确的抽屉里。
Todd opens the bottom drawer, and the treats are all there.
托德打开底下的抽屉，零食全在那里。
Another thing I learned talking to Todd about rats is that they can jump incredibly high, like bunnies. Todd learned this when he set up his GoPro to figure out how his rats were getting into these high cubbies. The footage showed they were crawling onto the kitchen table and launching themselves four feet in the air. Todd knows their secret, but they don't know he knows. A few days later, he wakes up.
我和托德谈论老鼠学到的另一件事是它们能跳得非常高，像兔子一样。托德是在架设GoPro弄清楚老鼠是怎么进入那些高处隔间时学到这一点的。录像显示它们爬上了餐桌，把自己发射到四英尺的空中。托德知道它们的秘密，但它们不知道他知道。几天后，他醒来。
And I walked into the living room, and I saw Claude. And he was running over to go do this, and then he kind of stopped and froze. He had been busted doing something naughty. And he walked up to the edge of the table, and I looked at him. And he kind of turned and looked at me, and then he turned and looked at the cubbies. And then he turned and looked at me again.
我走进客厅，我看到了克劳德。它正跑过去要做这件事，然后它停住了，僵住了。它做坏事被抓包了。它走到桌子边缘，我看着它。它转头看着我，然后它转头看着那些隔间。然后它又转头看着我。
And then he jumped straight up, just a couple-- the saddest little jump and just belly flopped onto the ground. He essentially tried to trick me into thinking that he could not make this jump that very easily could be done and I have seen them do now on camera many, many times. I was just like, did that just happen? Did this rat just try to trick me into thinking he couldn't do something I know he can do?
然后它垂直跳起，只是一个……最悲伤的小跳跃，然后肚子着地摔在地上。它本质上是想骗我以为它做不到这个跳跃，而这个动作可以很轻松地完成，而且我在摄像机上已经看到它们做过很多很多次了。我当时就想，刚才发生了什么？这只老鼠刚才是不是想骗我以为它做不到我知道它能做的事？
I talked to a rodent behavior specialist about all of this. He says Todd's got it mostly right. He wouldn't go so far as to say the rats were trying to trick Todd, but he said that rats know what will or won't get them treats from their owner, and they'll behave accordingly. What Todd is reading as intent is actually the nuance with which the rats can read the cues he's giving.
我采访了一位啮齿动物行为专家关于这一切。他说托德基本理解对了。他不会说得那么绝对，说老鼠是在试图欺骗托德，但他表示，老鼠知道什么会或什么不会从主人那里得到零食，它们会相应地调整行为。托德解读为意图的实际上是老鼠能够阅读他给出的线索的细微差别。
I was surprised when the rodent guy told me how perceptive they are. If you're stressed, a rat can smell that. They also study your posture. They read your facial expressions. They can detect things about us that we can't even see in each other. And they're social animals. If you like them and aren't trying to kill them, they want to play all day. They enjoy it, which Todd noticed.
当那位啮齿动物专家告诉我它们有多敏锐时，我很惊讶。如果你有压力，老鼠能闻到。它们还会研究你的姿势。它们阅读你的面部表情。它们能察觉到关于我们的一些我们甚至无法在彼此身上看到的东西。而且它们是社会性动物。如果你喜欢它们，并没有试图杀死它们，它们会整天想玩耍。它们享受这一点，托德也注意到了。
It was non-stop entertainment. They are always up to something. And also, they're so loving. They're one of the most loving creatures you could ever have as a pet. They just are obsessed with you. It's like--
那是不间断的娱乐。它们总是想搞点名堂。而且，它们非常有爱。它们是你作为宠物能拥有的最有爱的生物之一。它们就是着迷于你。这就像……
Wait, OK, this is the side of rats I do not know about. No one talks about rats, they're so loving. So can you just-- like, I need you to-- I need you to convince me that that's true.
等等，好吧，这是我不了解的老鼠的一面。没人谈论老鼠，它们是那么有爱。所以你能不能……就是，我需要你……我需要你让我相信那是真的。
That's fair. That's totally understandable. But as far as their loving nature is like, they just constantly want to come cuddle and kiss you and give you little licks. And so I fully admit that like I am pretty far off the deep end into pet rat ownership.
那是公平的。那完全可以理解。但关于它们有爱的天性，它们只是不断地想过来拥抱你，亲吻你，给你小舔舐。所以，我完全承认，我对宠物鼠的拥有已经深陷其中了。
But there's still another level that I haven't sunk to yet, which is a lot of people let their rats clean their teeth and stuff, which is disgusting to me. But rats love to groom you because that is like hugging and kissing. I think that I got a lot of booger eaters right now. They just always want to get in my nose and try to clean my boogers, which is like, dude, stop. That is disgusting.
但还有一个层次我还没沉沦进去，那就是很多人让它们清洁牙齿之类的，这对我来说很恶心。但老鼠喜欢为你梳理，因为那就像拥抱和亲吻。我觉得我现在有很多鼻屎食客。它们总是想钻进我的鼻子，试图清理我的鼻屎，这简直是，老兄，停下。那太恶心了。
Wait, you have a line?
等等，你有底线？
Oh, yeah, I do. I do. Yeah, I will not let them clean my teeth or boogers. The ear thing is like I don't want them crawling inside my ear, but it is really cute when they try to because you hear their little squeaks and sniffs, and that's pretty cute. But then once they start trying to get into your ear to clean it, it's like, dude, stop. That's disgusting.
哦，是的，我有。我有。是的，我不会让它们清理我的牙齿或鼻屎。耳朵的事情就像，我不希望它们爬进我的耳朵，但当它们尝试时真的很可爱，因为你能听到它们小小的吱吱声和嗅探声，那很可爱。但一旦它们开始试图钻进你的耳朵里清理它，那就像，老兄，停下。那太恶心了。
The idea of Todd being groomed by rats brings me back to his predicament.
托德被老鼠梳理的想法让我想起了他的困境。
When does the thought, OK, I need to get rid of these rats if I want to have love and a relationship, when does that occur to you?
什么时候那种，“好吧，如果我想拥有爱情和一段关系，我就得处理掉这些老鼠”的想法，是什么时候发生的？
Yeah, so for me, I feel like as the pandemic started kind of actually winding down a bit, I think the last variant, it felt like things were opening up again. I was going to parties again for the first time in a while and meeting people at parties. And I think I was at a friend's party, and the moment kind of occurred. I met a girl at this party, and we really hit it off. And we were flirting. And then we exchanged numbers.
是的，所以对我来说，我觉得当疫情开始真正有所缓和时，我想最后一个变种，感觉事情又开始开放了。我第一次在很长一段时间里又去参加派对，并在派对上认识人。我想我当时在朋友的派对上，那一刻某种程度上发生了。我在那个派对上认识了一个女孩，我们真的很投缘。我们当时在调情。然后我们交换了号码。
And then we kind of kept talking, and then she inquired about potentially getting a drink. So we get a drink after this party, and then as things were winding down, and the bar was closing, I think like anybody, you fall into old habits. You're like, OK, do you want to go back to my place? And she's like, yeah.
然后我们继续谈话，然后她询问关于可能喝一杯。所以我们在那个派对后去喝了一杯，然后当事情快结束，酒吧快关门时，我想像任何人一样，你会陷入旧习惯。你就像，好吧，你想去我家吗？她说，是的。
And it was like a Kaiser Soce moment, where all of a sudden, in my head, I was like, oh, my god, wait a minute. I have, at that point, 12 rats in my apartment. It had not even occurred to me like, I can't bring this person home to an apartment full of rats. I was like, the first thing that rushed through my mind is like, how do I explain this to her to preface this before we go to my apartment? And very quickly, I was like, there is no way to explain having 12 rats in your apartment.
那一刻就像“凯撒·索泽”时刻，突然之间，在我脑海里，我想，哦，天哪，等一下。在那一刻，我的公寓里有12只老鼠。我甚至没想过，就像，我不能把这个人带到一个满是老鼠的公寓。我心想，冲进我脑海的第一件事就是，在去我的公寓之前，我该怎么向她解释这个先决条件？很快，我就想，没法解释公寓里有12只老鼠。
They were in his car on the way home. Todd turns to the woman and says--
它们在他回家的车上。托德转向那个女人说——
Actually, I'm really sorry. I lied and said, I'm actually really, really tired, and I have an early morning tomorrow. And so this girl probably thought I was not that into her and having second thoughts when in reality, it was because I didn't want to expose her to a rat-filled apartment.
其实，我很抱歉。我撒谎说，我其实真的、真的很累，明天还要早起。所以这个女孩可能以为我对她没那么感兴趣，有别的想法，而实际上，这是因为我不想让她接触满是老鼠的公寓。
He takes her back to her car, and they never see each other again.
他把她送回车边，他们再也没见过面。
I remember laying in bed that night being like, well, this is probably the end of rat ownership. If we're going to be like meeting people again, life is kind of starting to get back to normal, this is not something that you can explain to somebody.
我记得那天晚上躺在床上想，好吧，这可能是养鼠的终点了。如果我们要像以前一样再次认识人，生活某种程度上开始恢复正常，这不是你能向别人解释的事情。
Todd's tried to get rid of the rats, posted them online, but then every time, he ends up backing out at the last minute, so much so that he's been banned from multiple online LA rat groups.
托德试图处理掉老鼠，把它们发布到网上，但每次，他最后关头都反悔了，以至于他被多个洛杉矶在线老鼠组织禁了。
3 and 1/2 weeks ago, I had a woman who was coming to adopt them who-- I feel really bad. She drove all the way from Simi Valley, and like a half hour before, I was like, I'm so sorry. I can't do this. I got to keep them. I'm really, really sorry. I offered to Venmo her for her gas. But she was like, no, don't worry about it, whatever. But yeah, it's really hard to get rid of them. I've tried quite a bit. It's tough.
3周半前，有一个女人要来领养它们，我……我觉得真的很抱歉。她一路从西米谷开车过来，就在半小时前，我说，我非常抱歉。我做不到。我必须留着它们。我真的、真的抱歉。我提议通过Venmo支付她的油费。但她说，不，没关系，无所谓。但是的，很难处理掉它们。我尝试过很多次。很难。
Oh, man. I don't think you're going to be able to do it.
哦，伙计。我不认为你能做到。
I know, but I have to. There's got to be a way.
我知道，但我必须。一定有办法。
Why do you have to?
为什么你必须？
This is definitely not a sustainable way of living life.
这绝对不是一种可持续的生活方式。
Todd told me he was planning on getting rid of all of his rats within a month.
托德告诉我，他计划在一个月内处理掉他所有的老鼠。
OK. Hi, Todd.
好的。嗨，托德。
Hi.
嗨。
[LAUGHS] All right, so it's been four months since we last talked.
[笑声] 好了，距离我们上次交谈已经过去四个月了。
Has it really been four months?
真的过去四个月了吗？
It's been four months, well, minus a few days. I'm dying to know, have you given away the rats?
已经四个月了，嗯，减去几天。我渴望知道，你把那些老鼠送走了吗？
I have not. I have, I feel like, made some progress in that I have committed to not getting any more rats or any new rats, which I think is a big step, a first step. I'm down to three now, unfortunately.
我没有。我觉得，我取得了一些进展，就是我承诺不再养更多的老鼠或任何新老鼠，我认为这是一个重大举措，第一步。不幸的是，我现在只剩下三只了。
You're down to three rats?
你只剩三只老鼠了？
Down to three rats, yeah.
只剩三只老鼠，是的。
Since Todd got most of them around the same time, many of them died around the same time. It's been hard. He's actively restraining himself when he has the urge to get more rats.
因为托德大多是在同一时间得到它们的，它们很多在同一时间死去了。这很难。他在有养更多老鼠的冲动时积极克制自己。
That takes discipline.
那需要自律。
What was the closest you came?
你最接近的一次是什么时候？
A week ago. Man, there was a really cute rat. There was a rat like a week ago that came from the same breed as one of my favorite rats, my first rat, Claude, that died that was just like, oh, he's the cutest and best little rat. And there was a really cute video that one of the rodent rescues posted, and it was like, yeah, he's up for adoption. I was like, man, four isn't that different than three. Maybe I'll just get one more and then see where that goes.
一周前。伙计，有一只真的很可爱的老鼠。就在一周前，有一只老鼠，和我的最爱之一，我的第一只老鼠克劳德的品种相同，那只老鼠死掉了，它就是，噢，它是最可爱、最好的小老鼠。其中一个啮齿动物救援机构发了一个真的很可爱的视频，就像，是的，它待领养。我当时想，伙计，四只和三只没多大区别。也许我会再养一只，然后看看会怎么样。
But he was a young rat, and I was like, if I get a fourth one that's young, then I'm going to have to get him a buddy when the other three die. And then now we're at two, and then you know where this goes from there. It spirals out of control pretty quickly.
但他是一只年轻的老鼠，我就想，如果我得到第四只年轻的，那么当其他三只死的时候，我就得给它找个伙伴。然后现在我们就两只了，然后你知道从那里开始会发生什么。它螺旋式地迅速失控。
So why is he finally letting go of his rats? What changed? After our first call, he started opening up to women on dating apps about his rat ownership. To his surprise, at least half were totally cool with it. He even brought four dates home to meet the rats. It went great. This huge obstacle he'd invented, rats or love, it wasn't actually a problem, which made him look at why he was so embarrassed about being a rat guy in the first place.
所以为什么他终于要放手他的老鼠了？什么改变了？在我们第一次通话后，他开始在约会软件上向女性开放他的养鼠情况。令他惊讶的是，至少有一半人完全接受。他甚至带了四个约会对象回家见老鼠。进展很顺利。他发明出的这个巨大障碍，老鼠还是爱情，实际上根本不是问题，这让他审视为什么他起初对成为一个养鼠男感到如此尴尬。
I think I was more embarrassed and ashamed of being, in general, who I was and where I was at that point. Obviously, the pandemic, everything that my identity was wrapped around had been paused. I love those rats. Do not get me wrong. And they are super fun.
我觉得我更多的是尴尬和羞耻，因为我当时是什么人，处在什么位置。显然，疫情，我身份围绕的一切都被暂停了。我爱那些老鼠。不要误解我。而且它们超级有趣。
But I think also, you could argue that I was using rat ownership as a way of avoiding addressing other problems in life because that's like the double whammy, is like, OK, I'm not pouring all this time into this weird hobby. That means I do have to pour it into getting my career back on track, addressing my personal life, addressing my love life, and actually taking those things serious. I don't have this great excuse anymore to avoid them.
但我认为，你也可以争辩说，我是在利用养鼠作为一种避免解决生活中其他问题的方式，因为那就像双重打击，就像，好吧，我没有把所有时间都投入到这个奇怪的爱好里。这意味着我确实必须把时间投入到让我的事业回归正轨，解决我的个人生活，解决我的爱情生活，并真正认真对待这些事情。我不再有这个伟大的借口来避免它们了。
Todd's taking steps to move towards a life without rats. He's taken down all the paintings and pictures the rats chewed the edges of and is replacing them with new art. The rats destroyed all his plants. He's buying new ones. And he's been going out on lots of dates. He feels hopeful about his new life, though he did say, when he's out buying new plants, maybe he'll see a new rat and get that, too.
托德正在采取步骤走向没有老鼠的生活。他摘掉了老鼠啃过边缘的所有画作和照片，并用新艺术品替换它们。老鼠破坏了他所有的植物。他正在买新的。他一直在进行很多约会。他对自己的新生活感到充满希望，尽管他说，当他出去买新植物时，也许他会看到一只新老鼠，也会把它养起来。
Elna Baker, she's a producer on this show and a real one to us rats. Coming up.
埃尔娜·贝克，她是这个节目的制作人，也是我们老鼠的真朋友。接下来。
No country for old rats. We visit a vast place that has somehow gotten rid of rats.
老鼠无处安身。我们参观了一个以某种方式消灭了老鼠的广阔地方。
That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio.
还有一分钟来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
When our program continues.
节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Must Be Rats on the Brain." My co-hosts today, New York street rats Reggie and Rachel.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“脑子里一定是老鼠”。我今天的联合主持人，纽约街头鼠雷吉和瑞秋。
Hello.
你好。
Hey, hey. How's it going?
嘿，嘿。怎么样？
We're here.
我们在这儿。
Oh, you guys. Welcome back to the second half. We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, "The Big Bag Theory."
哦，你们。欢迎回到下半场。我们已经到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“大袋理论”。
So the Mayor of New York and his new rat czar have declared this renewed war on rats that we talked about at the beginning of the show, this war that's supposedly going to be way more effective and lethal. But one thing about the entire project that's seems kind of absurd is that one big reason that there are so many rats is just really obvious. It's just completely out in the open, not complicated at all.
所以纽约市长和他的新灭鼠总管宣布了我们在节目开始时谈到的这场针对老鼠的重启战争，这场据说会更有效、更致命的战争。但关于整个项目有一件事看起来有点荒谬，那就是老鼠如此之多的一个大原因真的很明显。它完全公开，一点也不复杂。
That's right. Yeah, right, it's racism. Oh, no, I'm sorry. No, it's plastic bags. Yeah, excuse me.
没错。是的，对了，是种族主义。哦，不，抱歉。不，是塑料袋。是的，打扰一下。
The bags.
袋子。
Excuse me.
抱歉。
Yeah, the plastic bags. Yeah, yeah, yeah, the plastic. Yeah, that's the thing. New Yorkers put out their garbage in plastic bags. And if you've ever visited the city for more than a day, you've seen these. They're on the sidewalk at night, just huge stacks of them just stretching down the block. It's about 8 million pounds of food waste every day. That's one pound for every man, woman, child, and non-binary person in the five boroughs. And it is also a lot of rat food.
是的，塑料袋。是的，是的，是的，塑料。是的，就是那件事。纽约人把他们的垃圾放在塑料袋里。如果你在城市里待过超过一天，你就见过这些。它们晚上放在人行道上，成堆的垃圾一直延伸到街区尽头。每天大约有800万磅的食物垃圾。那是五个区里每个男人、女人、孩子和非二元性别者平均一磅。这也是大量的鼠粮。
It's like a buffet on every block. And you're saying, oh, no, don't eat the buffet food.
这就像每个街区都有个自助餐。而你在说，哦，不，不要吃自助餐的食物。
And is it very hard tearing into a plastic garbage bag?
而且把塑料垃圾袋撕开很难吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
No.
不。
Is it hard to walk?
走路难吗？
All right, all right, point taken. OK, so why, why, why would the biggest city in the country decide to do something so absurd and counterproductive? One of our producers, Ike Sriskandarajah, looked into that.
好了，好了，明白了。那么，为什么，为什么，为什么全国最大的城市会决定做如此荒谬且适得其反的事情？我们的制作人之一，艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾，调查了这个。
It wasn't always this way. New Yorkers used to take out their trash in Oscar the Grouch-style metal cans with tightly fitting lids. The cans were ubiquitous-- mostly worked, but nobody liked them. Here's how you used to have to take out the trash. You'd put your raw refuse in a metal can. A sanitation worker would drag it to the back of the truck, banging it loudly to empty it out, where New Yorkers, many without hoses, were left to clean out their smelly metal cans. It wasn't great.
以前不是这样的。纽约人过去把垃圾装在像“奥斯卡格鲁奇”式的带紧密盖子的金属罐里。罐子无处不在——大部分有效，但没人喜欢它们。这是你过去倒垃圾的方式。你把原始垃圾放入金属罐。一名清洁工会把它拖到卡车后面，大声撞击它以清空它，而纽约人，很多没有水管，不得不清理他们臭气熏天的金属罐。那感觉不太好。
Then, in the late '60s, the future arrived. America put a man on the moon. And--
然后，在60年代末，未来到来了。美国把一个人送上了月球。而——
Here's the answer, folks-- new Glad Trash Bags. They're odorproof, scatterproof, so strong they're leakproof. It's the end of trashy trash.
这是答案，伙计们——新的格莱德垃圾袋。它们防臭，防散落，坚固到防漏。这是垃圾垃圾的终结。
That's neat.
真整洁。
Plastic trash bags were mass produced for the first time. New York City Mayor John Lindsay saw an opportunity for an easy political win. He called a press conference on May 8, 1969. Reporters gathered in the Blue Room at City Hall. A garbage bag hung on the wall.
塑料垃圾袋首次被大规模生产。纽约市长约翰·林赛看到了一个轻松政治胜利的机会。他在1969年5月8日召开了一次新闻发布会。记者们聚集在市政厅的蓝厅。墙上挂着一个垃圾袋。
And Mayor Lindsay announced plans for a new experimental program that would allow New Yorkers in half a dozen neighborhoods to drop trash bags directly on the curb overnight. The mayor said he wanted to see if paper and plastic garbage bags could reduce noise, odor, litter, speed up garbage collection, and improve conditions for sanitation workers.
林赛市长宣布了一项新的实验计划，允许六个街区的纽约人在夜间将垃圾袋直接放在路边。市长说他想看看纸袋和塑料垃圾袋能否减少噪音、气味、乱扔垃圾，加快垃圾收集速度，并改善清洁工的工作条件。
The Sanitation Union was all in, but not everyone was so glad. Bobby Corrigan remembers where he was. These days, he's a world renowned rodentologist, but back then, he was taking an Intro to Pest Management class at SUNY Farmingdale. His professor asked the class to consider the mayor's recent announcement.
清洁工工会全力支持，但并非所有人都那么高兴。鲍比·科里根记得他当时在哪。如今，他是世界著名的啮齿动物学家，但那时，他正在纽约州立大学法明代尔分校上害虫管理导论课。他的教授让班级思考市长最近的公告。
I remember him giving us a lesson about that event. And he said, I want you to write a homework lesson. What do you think this is going to do for the rat population of the city to put trash in plastic bags? What will this do?
我记得他给我们上了关于那件事的一课。他说，我想让你们写个家庭作业。你们认为把垃圾放在塑料袋里会对城市的鼠群产生什么影响？这会产生什么后果？
Even the students in Pest Control 101 could tell what would happen.
即使是害虫防治101的学生也能看出会发生什么。
The writing was on the wall that if we do this, we're going to be literally as if it was a zoological garden. We're going to try to grow these animals for some reason.
墙上写着，如果我们这样做，我们将字面上就像这是一个动物园。出于某种原因，我们要试着养大这些动物。
Bobby thinks back on this moment often. In The Terminator version of this movie, which would be called Exterminator, the human survivors of New Rat City would send Bobby back to dive in front of the podium and knock the bag out of Mayor Lindsay's hand.
鲍比经常回想这一刻。在这部电影的《终结者》版本里，那将被命名为《灭虫者》，新老鼠市的人类幸存者会把鲍比送回讲台前扑过去，打掉林赛市长手中的袋子。
If I was there sitting in the audience or any pest professional, we all would have went, whoa, whoa, stop. We have questions back here in the back row. Stop, stop. My message would have-- I would have stood up and say, this is going to be a colossal mistake in public health and a colossal mistake in quality of life. And it needs to be stopped and rethink this whole thing with different approaches.
如果我当时坐在观众席或者任何害虫专业人士在那儿，我们所有人都会说，哇，哇，停下。我们在后排有疑问。停下，停下。我的信息会……我会站起来说，这将是公共健康的一个巨大错误，也是生活质量的一个巨大错误。它需要被停止，并用不同的方法重新思考这一切。
How pivotal was this moment in the history of the New York City rat population?
这个时刻在纽约市鼠群历史中有多关键？
I think it was everything. I think it put this animal into hyperdrive.
我认为这就是全部。我认为它让这种动物进入了超速状态。
He calls this "the Big Bang Theory," or "the Big Bag Theory," because he's funny. Right before the bags in 1969, another respected rodentologist named Joe Brooks did a survey and found that rats were only in 11% of New York. Now, Bobby says, rats are in 80% to 90% of the city.
他称这为“大爆炸理论”，或者“大袋理论”，因为他很幽默。在1969年袋子出现之前，另一位受人尊敬的啮齿动物学家乔·布鲁克斯做了一项调查，发现老鼠只在纽约的11%里出现。现在，鲍比说，老鼠出现在城市80%到90%的地方。
So did anyone in charge see this coming? If a bunch of undergrads in an entry-level pest class could tell, couldn't the people running the city? Fortunately, one of the men who brought plastic bags to New York is still alive. Jerry Kretchmer is now 88. Back then, he was acting sanitation commissioner. Jerry might be one of the last people left who can tell us definitively-- did they have any idea that plastic bags would lead to a ratpocalypse?
那么有没有负责人预见到这一点？如果一群害虫课入门级的本科生能看出来，经营这个城市的人为什么不能？幸运的是，把塑料袋带到纽约的人之一还活着。杰瑞·克雷奇默现在88岁。那时，他是代理清洁专员。杰瑞可能是最后剩下能确切告诉我们答案的人之一——他们是否知道塑料袋会导致“鼠启示录”？
In 1971, let's just say, if somebody would show me a plastic bag, I would think, that's easy to fill, that's easy to pick up, and they're easy to collect. Those are the things that I would have thought about it. I wouldn't have thought that rats could eat them because that wasn't what I was concerned with. My concern is collecting the garbage.
在1971年，我们这么说吧，如果有人给我看一个塑料袋，我会想，那很容易装满，很容易捡起，很容易收集。这就是我会想到的事情。我不会想到老鼠会吃它们，因为那不是我所关心的。我关心的是收集垃圾。
Is that trade-off worth it?
那个权衡值得吗？
I don't know if it's worth it. My story is we got to get the garbage collected.
我不知道它是否值得。我的故事是我们必须收集垃圾。
Rats were not on Jerry's radar at all. He was busy removing millions of pounds of garbage from the city every day, which, by the way, is kind of a miracle. And bags? They made that massive job faster, 20% faster.
老鼠根本不在杰瑞的雷达上。他忙于每天从城市移除数百万磅的垃圾，顺便说一句，这本身就是个奇迹。而袋子？它们使那项巨大的工作更快了，快了20%。
Where the city saw efficiency, big bag saw dollar signs. Bagmakers primed the public by donating 600,000 sacks and even got to help pick the guy who evaluated the pilot project. At the initial press conference, that guy claimed the bags would reduce the smell so much that they wouldn't attract rats, which, as any New Yorker who has walked past a pile of black bags baking under the hot sun can tell you, it's just a total lie.
在城市看到效率的地方，大袋子看到了美元符号。袋子制造商通过捐赠60万个袋子吸引公众，甚至帮忙挑选了评估试点项目的人。在最初的新闻发布会上，那个人声称袋子会减少气味，以至于它们不会吸引老鼠，这，正如任何走过在烈日下烘烤的黑色袋子堆的纽约人所能告诉你的，纯粹是个谎言。
In January 1971, the city council unanimously voted to approve the use of plastic bags in all five boroughs of New York. Cans were out, bags were in, and the party began. Oh, to be a New York City rat in the 1970s.
1971年1月，市议会一致投票通过在纽约所有五个区使用塑料袋。罐子被淘汰，袋子被引入，派对开始了。哦，做1970年代的一只纽约市老鼠真好。
Now it's 2023.
现在是2023年。
I don't think you're going to find an administration that is more serious about containers and placing our garbage in containers, like we are.
我不认为你能找到一个比我们更认真对待容器并将垃圾放入容器的政府了。
That, of course, is Mayor Eric Adams. And the big thing he and his new rat czar are doing to take back the city from rats is to get trash bags back in trash cans. But Adams is putting millions of dollars into a new pilot that undoes Mayor Lindsay's pilot. It puts trash into sleek modern bins. It's ambitious, bold, but here's why it might not work.
那，当然，是市长埃里克·亚当斯。他和他的新灭鼠总管为了从老鼠手中夺回城市正在做的大事就是把垃圾袋放回垃圾桶里。但亚当斯正投入数百万美元进行一项新试点，废除林赛市长的试点。它把垃圾放入时髦的现代垃圾箱里。这雄心勃勃，大胆，但这是它可能不奏效的原因。
The new containers need to be picked up more often, daily or even twice a day. This would require hiring more sanitation workers. And buying new special sideloading trucks could cost hundreds of millions of dollars over the next decade.
新的容器需要更频繁地收集，每天甚至一天两次。这将需要雇佣更多的清洁工。而购买新的特殊侧装卡车在未来十年内可能花费数亿美元。
And then there's the parking spots. To make the plan work, the city would need to place the containers in 150,000 parking spots, up to 25% of spots in some neighborhoods. So are New Yorkers willing to give up their parking in order to beat back rats?
然后还有停车位。为了使计划奏效，城市需要在15万个停车位中放置容器，在某些街区占车位的25%。所以纽约人愿意放弃他们的停车位以打击老鼠吗？
I don't want to give up a parking spot. It's hard enough to find a parking spot.
我不想放弃停车位。找停车位已经够难了。
You can't get a spot as it is around here, just when you come home at night. Forget about it.
这儿本来就没地方，晚上回家时，别想了。
I'd rather get rid of the rat problem. That's much more important. I mean, this is a walking city, so it's easy.
我宁愿解决老鼠问题。那更重要。我的意思是，这是一个步行城市，所以这很容易。
Give up the spots.
放弃车位。
150,000. Where are they gonna park? In Jersey?
15万。他们去哪儿停？在泽西？
You're asking like two very intense things in New York-- finding a spot to park, but not wanting problems with a rat. That is-- 150,000?
你像是在纽约问两个非常强烈的事情——找车位，但不想有老鼠问题。那……15万？
You gotta make sacrifices.
你得做出牺牲。
You gotta make sacrifices, but that means people gotta spend more money going to like parking garages. Oh, I'm going to have to say no.
你得做出牺牲，但那意味着人们得花更多的钱去那种停车场。哦，我不得不说不。
I don't care at all.
我一点也不在乎。
Same, it doesn't affect me. I don't think I care. I don't think I care whatsoever.
同感，它不影响我。我不认为我在乎。我不认为我在乎任何事情。
Parking spots aren't affecting me.
停车位不影响我。
It was mixed, pretty much split. Humans are a house divided. Rats, they're united. They know what they need to do. And that's why they're winning.
情况很复杂，基本上一分为二。人类是一个分裂的房子。老鼠，它们团结一致。它们知道它们需要做什么。这就是为什么它们在赢。
Ike Sriskandarajah, he's a producer on our show.
艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾，他是我们节目的制作人。
Act 3, Alberta? More like "Al-mur-dah" a lot of rats!
第三幕，阿尔伯塔？简直是“阿尔-没-鼠”多了！
All right, so nearly everywhere there are people, there are rats. They thrive living off our agriculture and our garbage. They've followed us wherever we've settled.
好了，所以几乎在有人的地方，就有老鼠。它们以我们的农业和垃圾为生，茁壮成长。我们到哪里定居，它们就跟到哪里。
We followed you? Some nerve!
我们跟着你们？真有胆子！
[LAUGHS] Hey, hey, he's the main character.
[笑声] 嘿，嘿，他是主角。
[LAUGHS] So you're saying it's more of a partnership.
[笑声] 所以你是说这更像是一种伙伴关系。
Absolutely.
绝对是。
Come on.
得了吧。
Well, I'm just saying that as people spread around the globe, like rats, most of the rats that are across New York and across America, they started in China and Mongolia, right?
嗯，我只是说，随着人类在全球散布，就像老鼠，大多数在纽约和美国各地出现的老鼠，它们起源于中国和蒙古，对吧？
That's right, Mongolia and then got to Europe.
没错，蒙古然后到了欧洲。
And then we got on the boats and just headed out to everywhere. Everywhere Europeans went, the rats went.
然后我们上了船，径直去了各地。欧洲人去了哪里，老鼠就跟到了哪里。
That's actually the truth. And if you want to find places where there aren't rats, you basically have to go to places where there are no people, like Antarctica. There are islands here and there. But there is one big exception to all this. The largest place of human habitation where there are no rats-- Alberta, Canada. Alberta, Canada, is a province of Canada roughly the size of California and Oregon combined. It's bigger than France. And it's done something that humans elsewhere have failed at completely-- they have no rats. How is that possible? How did they do it?
那确实是事实。如果你想找到没有老鼠的地方，你基本上得去没有人烟的地方，比如南极洲。到处都有岛屿。但这一切有一个巨大的例外。人类居住的没有老鼠的最大的地方——加拿大阿尔伯塔。加拿大阿尔伯塔是加拿大的一个省，面积大约相当于加利福尼亚州和俄勒冈州的总和。它比法国还大。它做了一些人类在其他地方彻底失败的事情——它们没有老鼠。这怎么可能？他们是怎么做到的？
We are a couple miles west of the Saskatchewan border. It's kind of like the front line, I guess. And there's no doubt that's where the rats show up.
我们在萨斯喀彻温边界以西几英里处。我想这就像前线。毫无疑问，那就是老鼠出现的地方。
I'm riding through the Alberta countryside with rat inspector Jory Hoffman. It's green and mostly flat, open space that, to an American like me, looks very Midwestern, farm after farm. And the towns near the border are tiny. Jory's 29, straight-talking guy who volunteers at the fire department and small town events in a T-shirt, jeans, and baseball cap. His feelings about this line of work are uncomplicated.
我和灭鼠专家乔里·霍夫曼骑车穿过阿尔伯塔乡村。这里绿意盎然，大部分平坦，开阔的空间，对像我这样的美国人来说，看起来很中西部，农场挨着农场。边界附近的城镇很小。乔里29岁，直言不讳的人，在消防部门做志愿者，在小镇活动中穿着T恤、牛仔裤和棒球帽。他对于这份工作的感受并不复杂。
I like my job. I like the outdoors. So, spray weeds, go look for rats. [LAUGHS] Something new every day. I'm an everyday farmer, so I enjoy it.
我喜欢我的工作。我喜欢户外。所以，喷洒杂草，去寻找老鼠。[笑声] 每天都有新东西。我是个日常农民，所以我很享受。
Rat hunting is just five weeks in the spring and fall for him. When he's not doing that, he's working the farm his family's had for five generations near here. He knows most of the farmers here along the border. Also in the truck is Karen Wickerson, who runs Alberta's rat control program. She explains that Alberta's campaign against rats began decades ago.
灭鼠对他来说只是春季和秋季的五周。他不干那个的时候，在附近经营着他家族已经在这里经营了五代的农场。他认识这里沿边境的大多数农民。卡车里还有运行阿尔伯塔灭鼠项目的凯伦·威克森。她解释说，阿尔伯塔针对老鼠的运动始于几十年前。
If you picture for a second, OK, rats arrive on the East Coast of North America and then slowly spread west across the continent, and in Canada, what that means is they infiltrate Quebec province, and then they move west to Ontario province, then Manitoba province. Karen says they reached the Saskatchewan province surprisingly not that long ago, around 1920.
如果你想象一下，好吧，老鼠到达北美东海岸，然后慢慢向西横穿大陆，而在加拿大，那意味着它们渗透进魁北克省，然后它们向西移动到安大略省，然后马尼托巴省。凯伦说它们令人惊讶地没多久前到达了萨斯喀彻温省，大约在1920年左右。
And it took them 30 years to move across the province to get to the Alberta-Saskatchewan border. And essentially, we saw the rats coming. And so we're able to mobilize and be ready for when they arrived.
它们花了30年穿过省份到达阿尔伯塔-萨斯喀彻温边境。本质上，我们看到了老鼠的到来。所以我们能够动员起来，为它们到达时做好准备。
That day came in 1950. People in Alberta would cross the border to Saskatchewan and saw that rats were infiltrating farms and eating crops. Alberta is a big agricultural province, and Albertans were like, nope, we don't want the rats.
那一天是在1950年。阿尔伯塔的人们穿过边境到萨斯喀彻温，看到老鼠正在渗透进农场并吃掉农作物。阿尔伯塔是一个农业大省，阿尔伯塔人就像，不，我们不想要老鼠。
And therefore, they were declared a pest so that every Albertan was responsible for controlling them. And they actively went out and educated people as well because people didn't know what rats looked like. They had rats taxidermied and put in all the local agricultural field offices, just so that they could see what a rat actually looked like.
因此，它们被宣布为害虫，以便每个阿尔伯塔人都有责任控制它们。他们积极走出去并教育人们，因为人们不知道老鼠长什么样。他们把老鼠制成标本，并放在所有当地农业领域办公室，这样他们就能看到老鼠真正长什么样。
They also decided to set up a rat control zone, kind of a DMZ for rats, where they'd catch the vermin trying to infiltrate the pristine province to ravage their crops. The zone runs along the border with Saskatchewan, north to south, over 300 miles, 18 miles wide. That's where we are right now, in this truck. Twice a year, Karen has 13 people that go out to inspect every farm and every spot where rats might nest. Jory's on his spring inspection today. He turns the truck into a driveway of a farm. We see four big steel grain bins. There's some farm equipment in the yard.
他们还决定建立一个灭鼠区，某种程度上是老鼠的非军事区，他们会在那里抓捕试图渗透进这个原始省份去毁坏农作物的害虫。这个区域沿着萨斯喀彻温边境，南北走向，超过300英里，18英里宽。那就是我们现在所在的地方，在这辆卡车里。每年两次，凯伦有13个人出去检查每个农场和老鼠可能筑巢的每个地方。乔里今天在进行春季检查。他把卡车开进一个农场的车道。我们看到四个巨大的钢制粮仓。院子里有一些农用设备。
OK, we're pulling into where?
好的，我们正开进哪里？
Just a very suspect area. I've had an infestation at this yard before. So there was hundreds here inside this burning pit.
只是一个非常可疑的区域。我以前在这个院子里处理过虫害。所以这里这个燃烧坑里有几百只。
We climb out of the truck to see if the rats have returned. The burning pit is 8 feet or 10 feet deep and the length of a good-sized swimming pool with a tangle of stuff sticking up the farmer wants to set ablaze and get rid of. There's dead trees, barbed wire fencing, cow bones.
我们爬出卡车，看看老鼠是否回来了。那个燃烧坑有8英尺或10英尺深，长度相当于一个大游泳池，里面堆满了农民想放火烧掉清理的东西。有死树、带刺铁丝网围栏、牛骨。
Yeah, so what we're doing here, we're just going to walk around this burning pit. And we're looking on the edges for holes, rat runs. You can tell they use the same track over and over, so you can tell where they've been.
是的，所以我们要在这里做的是，我们只是要绕着这个燃烧坑走。我们在边缘寻找洞、老鼠奔跑的痕迹。你可以看出它们一遍又一遍地使用同一条轨道，所以你可以看出它们去过哪里。
Now, Jory, you're climbing down. What are you pointing at?
现在，乔里，你正在爬下去。你在指什么？
There's a hole there. It could be a hole.
那儿有个洞。那可能是一个洞。
That hole is around 3 inches around.
那个洞大约3英寸大。
Yep, yeah. It could be a rat. It could be new. Could be a gopher or a weasel or anything.
是的，是的。那可能是一只老鼠。它可能是新的。可能是地鼠、黄鼠狼或者其他什么。
We spot dozens of other holes, big and small, but no signs of life. No rat feces or food by the holes. Jory concludes there are probably no rats here, and we go on to other farms. We're usually in and out in just a few minutes, look around some bales of barley or oats, open doors to steel grain bins. The fact that we find zero rats, that's typical. Jory has 500 locations he inspects. And the number of actual infestations he discovers, like a real nest with dozens or hundreds of rats--
我们发现了许多其他大大小小的洞，但没有生命迹象。洞旁边没有鼠粪或食物。乔里断定这里可能没有老鼠，我们去了其他农场。我们通常在几分钟内进出，绕着一些大麦或燕麦捆看看，打开钢制粮仓的门。我们发现零只老鼠，那是典型的。乔里有500个检查点。而他发现的实际虫害数量，就像真正有几十或几百只老鼠的巢穴——
Once every two years.
每两年一次。
Wow. So it's a bad infestation once every two years, and then how many other times will you find a rat, let's say, in a year?
哇。所以每两年一次严重的虫害，然后你在一年里还会发现其他多少次老鼠呢？
Like last year, I found one, one solo, and probably none the year before that, maybe none the year before that.
就像去年，我发现了一只，只有一只，前年可能没有，大前年可能也没有。
There must be a part of you where you kind of wish you hope you find something, so you have something to do.
你心里肯定有一部分会有点希望找到点什么，这样你就有点事做。
Yeah. So you have to remind yourself sometimes why you're doing it because it can get fairly dry. I've been to all these yards so many times in my life, it's the same thing every time.
是的。所以你有时不得不提醒自己为什么要这样做，因为它可能会变得相当枯燥。我这辈子去过这些院子太多次了，每次都是一样。
This is the dirty secret of the world's most effective rat control program-- they have done such a good job that at this point, it's kind of boring. Jory and Karen both used that word. It's like Jory is Batman, and every night he goes out looking for criminals and never, ever finds them, though I should say it took them a long time to get to this point.
这是世界上最有效的灭鼠项目的肮脏秘密——他们工作做得太好了，以至于在这一点上，它有点无聊。乔里和凯伦都用了那个词。就像乔里是蝙蝠侠，每天晚上出去寻找罪犯却从来、从来没找到它们，尽管我应该说他们花了很长时间才达到这个点。
Back in the first years of the program in the 1950s, Karen says, the teams would discover 600 infestations a year in the rat control zone along the border. By the 1960s, they still needed 250 pest control officers to fan out and kill rats. Today, like I said, it's just 13 people. Instead of 600 infestations a year, it'll be just two to five. Take that in a second-- just two to five infestations in over 300 miles of border.
在项目的头几年，在1950年代，凯伦说，团队每年会在沿边境的灭鼠区发现600起虫害。到了1960年代，他们仍然需要250名害虫防治官员分散出去杀老鼠。今天，就像我说的，只有13个人。与其每年600起虫害，只有2到5起。想一下，在超过300英里的边境线上只有2到5起虫害。
One thing that helps them keep the numbers low-- I thought this was interesting-- was the death of the family farm. In Canada, just like in the US, so many small farmers have gone out of business over the last half century. The remaining farms are really far apart. So if rats stow away in feed or supplies and then land on a farm, it's hard for them to migrate to a neighbor. Consolidation of farms hasn't just been bad for small farmers-- it's been bad for rats.
有一件事帮助他们保持数量低——我觉得这很有趣——是家庭农场的消亡。在加拿大，就像在美国，很多小农场在过去半个世纪倒闭了。剩下的农场隔得很远。所以如果老鼠藏在饲料或补给品中然后落在一个农场，它们很难迁移到邻居那里。农场合并不仅对小农场主来说是坏事——这对老鼠来说也是坏事。
Then, when you find some, it's exciting when you find some.
然后，当你发现一些的时候，当你发现一些的时候很令人兴奋。
You get a sense of just how monotonous Jory's job usually is when he talks about the last big infestation he cleaned out. It's especially memorable because instead of using poison, which is the normal way they handle it, the landowner is the one who discovered the rats. They told Jory, why don't you come out and bring a shotgun?
当乔里谈论他清理掉的最后一次大规模虫害时，你能感觉到他的工作通常是多么单调。它特别令人难忘，因为 landowner不是使用毒药，那是他们处理它的通常方式，而是 landowner发现了老鼠。他们告诉乔里，为什么你不出来带把猎枪呢？
They had me out, and they supplied all the bullets, all the shotgun shells. And I brought my shotgun out and my other three friends, and we'd shoot, stand in a horseshoe. It's kind of like you're shooting clay pigeons or skeet, if you know what that is. Yeah, and they just go running out of the holes, and you get time to shoot them and then reload. It was a ton of fun. Four good friends and four shotguns, and yeah, that was a great day.
他们让我出来，他们提供了所有的子弹，所有的霰弹枪弹药。我带上了我的猎枪和我的另外三个朋友，我们站成马蹄形。那感觉有点像你在射泥鸽或飞碟，如果你知道那是什么的话。是的，它们只是跑出洞来，你有时间射击它们然后重新装弹。那真是有趣。四个好朋友和四把猎枪，是的，那是棒极了的一天。
It was my first infestation, too. Yeah, yeah, I had just started being mentored by my predecessor, so it was pretty exciting that I actually got to go out and see rats on my first day.
那也是我的第一次虫害。是的，是的，我刚开始由我的前任指导，所以能真正出来并看到老鼠真是太令人兴奋了。
That was about three years ago. When Karen talks about what was so great about this, she says a sentence you cannot imagine a New Yorker uttering in the same tone of voice.
那大约是三年前。当凯伦谈论这个有什么好时，她说了一句你无法想象纽约人会以同样语气说出来的话。
I actually got to see live rats.
我真的能看到活老鼠。
I told Jory I was worried that people would hear his glee over shooting rats and think he's a monster. He said it was actually a quicker death than poison. Probably less painful.
我告诉乔里，我担心人们会听到他对射杀老鼠的欢呼，会认为他是怪物。他说这实际上比毒药死得更快。可能痛苦更少。
Of course, if you truly want to keep Alberta rat-free, you can't just patrol the border. Stray rats can hitch a ride on a truck or a car and land in Calgary or Edmonton or one of the other big cities or towns in the middle of the province. When that happens-- and it does happen-- Albertans are supposed to notify Karen's office.
当然，如果你真的想保持阿尔伯塔没有老鼠，你不能只巡逻边界。流浪老鼠可以搭卡车或汽车的顺风车，降落在卡尔加里或埃德蒙顿，或者省中间的其他大城市或城镇。当这种情况发生时——确实会发生——阿尔伯塔人应该通知凯伦的办公室。
There used to be a phone number you could call if you spot a rat, dead or alive, anywhere in the province. But Karen streamlined the process by creating an email address, so people can just shoot a photo of the suspect critter and send it to her. Back in the truck, she pulled out her phone and opened an email folder overfilled with hundreds of rodent pics.
过去有一个电话号码，如果你在省内任何地方发现老鼠，死活不论，都可以拨打。但凯伦简化了这个流程，创建了一个电子邮件地址，所以人们只需拍摄那只可疑动物的照片并发送给她。在卡车里，她拿出手机，打开了一个装满数百张啮齿动物照片的电子邮件文件夹。
I got a couple on Friday, a couple on Thursday. So this photo here, this is pretty typical. I know right away when I look at it, it is a muskrat.
我周五收到一对，周四收到一对。所以这张照片，这是非常典型的。我一看就知道，它是只麝鼠。
A muskrat is not a rat. It's bigger, puffier. But Karen says she faces a funny problem from Albertans reporting rats.
麝鼠不是老鼠。它更大、更蓬松。但凯伦说她面临着一个来自阿尔伯塔人举报老鼠的有趣问题。
Albertans don't know. If you've lived in Alberta your whole life, you've never seen a rat. So identifying it is pretty hard.
阿尔伯塔人不知道。如果你一辈子住在阿尔伯塔，你就从来没见过老鼠。所以识别它真的很困难。
Last year, of the 408 reports that Karen got, only 27 were rats. The official stats actually list the others as non-rats. Sometimes, of course, people do bring in rats intentionally to the province as pets. But in Alberta, that is breaking the law. And now and then, Albertans will drop a dime on rat pet owners, even on people they know.
去年，凯伦收到的408份报告中，只有27只是老鼠。官方统计实际上把其他的列为非老鼠。有时，当然，人们确实有意把老鼠作为宠物带进省里。但在阿尔伯塔，那是触犯法律。偶尔，阿尔伯塔人会举报宠物鼠主人，即使是举报他们认识的人。
Like, sometimes, it can be a bad breakup. [LAUGHS] And-- this has happened. And yeah, so people have been ratted out to me.
比如，有时，它可能是一场糟糕的分手。[笑声] 而且……这发生过。所以人们举报给了我。
And this case was an ex-boyfriend who ratted out his ex. She was not happy about this. Karen did what she does in these cases. She gives you a week to find your rat a home in another province. If you don't succeed, they euthanize your pet.
而这个案例是一个举报了前任的前男友。她对此并不高兴。凯伦在这些案例中做了她该做的。她给你一周时间去在另一个省份给你的老鼠找个家。如果你不成功，他们会安乐死你的宠物。
Whenever anybody tries to estimate how much money Alberta saves by having no rats, the numbers are in the tens of millions. That's crops that weren't eaten and infrastructure that wasn't degraded. The cost each year to keep rats out of Alberta? Shockingly low-- roughly $270,000 American, which is about half the price of one New York City garbage truck.
每当有人试图估算阿尔伯塔通过没有老鼠节省了多少钱时，数字都在数千万美元。那是没被吃掉的庄稼和没被退化的基础设施。每年让老鼠远离阿尔伯塔的成本？低得令人震惊——大约27万美元，大约是一辆纽约市垃圾车价格的一半。
The low cost and Alberta's success at keeping out rats is partly thanks to some lucky geography, Karen says, namely, they only have to patrol one border. Rats don't come in from the west because there are mountains. Rats apparently don't cross mountains. They don't come up from the US because Karen says it's too far between food sources. And they won't come down from the north because it's too cold for rats up there.
低成本和阿尔伯塔在阻挡老鼠方面的成功部分归功于一些幸运的地理环境，凯伦说，即，他们只需要巡逻一个边界。老鼠不会从西边进来，因为有山脉。老鼠显然不越过山脉。它们不会从美国上来，因为凯伦说食物来源之间太远了。它们不会从北边下来，因为那里的天气对老鼠来说太冷了。
OK, so the humans of Alberta have banded together in a civic-minded mission that no other members of our species have been as successful at. I was very interested to find out, is that a big deal to Albertans? Do they feel a sense of achievement? Do they feel a sense of pride about that?
好了，所以阿尔伯塔的人类联合起来执行了一项公民意识的任务，没有任何其他我们物种的成员能像这样成功。我非常想知道，这对阿尔伯塔人来说是个大事吗？他们感到一种成就感吗？他们对那感到自豪吗？
Excuse me, are you from Alberta?
打扰一下，你是来自阿尔伯塔吗？
My producer, Alaa, and I approached Albertans on a drizzly day outside a compound full of animals that they do allow into the province. We were at the zoo. No, there's no rat exhibit. We checked. And we asked everybody to name the things that make Alberta special and different, wondering how many of them would mention their epic ratlessness. Here's what they said.
我的制作人阿拉和我接近了在动物园外多雨的一天里的阿尔伯塔人，那里全是他们允许进入省份的动物。不，没有老鼠展览。我们查过了。我们请每个人说出让阿尔伯塔特别和不同的事情，好奇他们中有多少人会提到他们史诗般的“无鼠”。这是他们说的。
The national parks.
国家公园。
Cost of living.
生活成本。
The scenic routes are much more closer than you think.
风景优美的路线比你想象的要近得多。
Diversity lately.
最近的多样性。
Gas prices. This is the land of oil and gas, I guess.
汽油价格。我猜，这是石油和天然气之地。
Notice what nobody's mentioning?
注意到没人提到什么吗？
The wildlife. There's all the lakes and all the arboreal forest to the north.
野生动物。北部有所有的湖泊和所有的针叶林。
The mountains.
山脉。
Ooh, the Rocky Mountains for sure.
哦，洛矶山脉肯定是的。
We talked to a few dozen people. Not one mentioned rats.
我们和几十个人谈过。没有一个提到老鼠。
So the reason why I'm asking is because do you know about the rat situation in Alberta?
所以为什么我问这个是因为你知道阿尔伯塔的老鼠情况吗？
No.
不知道。
There is no rat situation.
没有老鼠情况。
Say more.
多说点。
I don't know. They've kept them out. They've had policies to keep them out ever since I can remember. So there are no rats.
不知道。他们把它们挡在外面。自从我记得以来，他们就有让他们远离的政策。所以没有老鼠。
I take it from this conversation that isn't like a point of pride or something.
从这个谈话中我得出的结论是，这不是像一种自豪的观点之类的。
No rats?
没有老鼠？
Yeah.
是啊。
No.
没有。
No, not really. Honestly, I literally hadn't thought about it until you brought it up just now.
不，并不是真的。老实说，直到你刚才提到它，我真的还没想到这一点。
Lots of people said they knew there were no rats. They're glad about it, but it is not a point of pride. This is the thing. When something is not around, you don't think about it. As one teenager put it--
很多人说他们知道没有老鼠。他们为此感到高兴，但这并不是一种自豪感。就是这件事。当某件事不在身边时，你不会想到它。正如一个青少年所说——
That's like thinking why there's no giraffes walking around here. Like, it's just kind of normal to us. [LAUGHS]
那就像在想为什么这里没有长颈鹿走来走去。就像，对我们来说那很正常。[笑声]
Also, it turns out life in Alberta is not so different from life in the rat-filled rest of human civilization because Alberta has its own share of pests. In fact, as we stood there outside the zoo, an animal ran by us on the grass, and the family we were talking to was like, oh, yeah, gophers. They're everywhere.
而且，事实证明阿尔伯塔的生活和人类文明被老鼠填满的其他地方没什么不同。事实上，当我们站在动物园外面时，一只动物跑过我们旁边的草地，我们正在谈话的家庭就像，哦，是的，地鼠。它们到处都是。
You see them a lot. We probably have as many groundhogs and prairie dogs as New York has rats.
你经常看到它们。我们可能拥有和纽约拥有老鼠一样多的土拨鼠和草原犬鼠。
Out in the rat control zone, on the border, Karen and Jory confirmed that of all the pests they have in the province-- mice, muskrats, wild feral pigs-- the worst one is gophers. Anyway, that's what everybody calls them-- gophers. But as Karen points out, they're actually Richardson ground squirrels.
在灭鼠区，在边界上，凯伦和乔里证实，在他们省拥有的所有害虫中——老鼠、麝鼠、野生野猪——最糟糕的是地鼠。总之，每个人都称它们为地鼠。但正如凯伦指出的，它们实际上是理查森地松鼠。
You could call it the menace out here. [LAUGHS]
你可以称它为这儿的威胁。[笑声]
There's a war against gophers for sure. There's an extreme war against gophers, so.
确实有针对地鼠的战争。肯定有一场针对地鼠的极端战争，所以。
So in your farm, do you have to put out poisons for the gophers?
所以你的农场里，你必须为地鼠投放毒药吗？
Yeah, or else, you have to be like my dad and shoot a few hundred a day. Or else, they'll like-- we still don't have them under control. There's just thousands. You could sit in one spot all day and shoot gophers without moving.
是的，否则，你得像我爸爸一样，每天射杀几百只。否则，它们会……我们仍然没法控制它们。有成千上万只。你可以在一个地方坐一整天射杀地鼠而不用移动。
And then there's just holes, and it makes you feel rough and bouncy and messy. And they'll eat your grain. They're terrible. I hate them. I bet my dad has shot probably 2,000 gophers already this season. Any time he's not too busy working, that's what he goes and does.
然后就是到处都是洞，让你感觉坑坑洼洼、有弹性且脏乱。它们会吃你的谷物。它们很糟糕。我恨它们。我敢打赌我爸爸这个季节已经射杀了大约2000只地鼠了。任何时候只要他不忙于工作，那就是他去做的。
So wait. So but then you're out here keeping the rats out, but you have this other pest that just as bad almost.
等等。所以……但你在这儿把老鼠挡在外面，但你有这个其他差不多一样糟糕的害虫。
Well, yeah, this one we can eradicate, and that one is too far gone. There's nothing we can do about it, really.
嗯，是的，这个我们可以消灭，而那个已经太严重了。关于它，我们真的无能为力。
Well, and they're native.
嗯，而且它们是原生的。
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
Whereas a Norway or roof rat is not. It's an invasive species.
而挪威鼠或屋顶鼠不是。那是入侵物种。
I know, but just because they're Canadian doesn't mean they're not terrible for you.
我知道，但仅仅因为它们是加拿大的并不意味着它们对你来说不糟糕。
Yeah. Yeah, it does, doesn't it?
是的。是的，确实如此，不是吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Standing there in the rat control zone, Karen did try to make the case that rats are way worse than gophers. Gophers don't move into a house or grain bin and leave their pee and poo. They don't chew through floors and do the same kinds of destruction. But in the end, what it comes down to is, gophers are Canadian. So what are you going to do? Like rats in New York, you can kill a few thousand here or there, but they're not going away. Even in a province that's done the impossible, some things are truly impossible.
站在灭鼠区，凯伦确实试图证明老鼠比地鼠糟糕得多。地鼠不会搬进房子或粮仓，留下它们的尿和屎。它们不会啃穿地板做同样程度的破坏。但最后，问题归结为，地鼠是加拿大的。所以你能做什么呢？就像纽约的老鼠，你可以在这儿或那儿杀几千只，但它们不会消失。即使在一个做到了不可能的省份，有些事情确实是不可能的。
So what do you guys think? You can't enter Alberta, Canada.
所以你们认为呢？你们不能进入加拿大阿尔伯塔。
Oh, no.
哦，不。
Oh, so sad.
哦，太悲伤了。
Oh, no. Hey, Rachel. Oh, no, we don't get to go to Canada.
哦，不。嘿，瑞秋。哦，不，我们去不了加拿大。
Oh, don't get to eat a bunch of sloppy poutine and fart all night.
哦，吃不到一堆马虎的肉汁奶酪薯条然后整夜放屁。
Hey, you want to catch a game by the Edmonton Oilers?
嘿，你想看一场埃德蒙顿油人队的比赛吗？
OK, now it's time for Act Four, "Hey, Put That Down. You Can't Eat That."
好了，现在是第四幕的时间，“嘿，把它放下。你不能吃那个。”
OK, so this is another story that you guys organized for us. Just explain what you did.
好的，所以这是你们为我们组织的另一个故事。简单解释一下你们做了什么。
Yeah, what we did was-- Rachel, you want to talk a little--
是的，我们做的是……瑞秋，你想谈谈……
Yeah, yeah, so we went under Delancey Street.
是的，是的，所以我们去了德兰西街下面。
Great street.
伟大的街道。
We got some microphones. We set it up in a real rat's nest. So this is going to be a real treat for you. You don't get to hear this very much. We're very private inside the rat's nest.
我们拿了些麦克风。我们在真正的老鼠窝里架设了它。所以这对你们来说是个真正的享受。你们通常听不到这个。我们在老鼠窝里非常私密。
So those of you who like film, this is called verite.
所以那些喜欢电影的人，这叫真实电影。
This is real rats talking real issues.
这是真正的老鼠在谈论真正的问题。
Talk about that real rat.
谈谈那只真正的老鼠。
Real rat.
真正的老鼠。
Real rat, yes.
真正的老鼠，是的。
Real rat rat.
真正的老鼠鼠。
Real real rat rat.
真正的真正的老鼠鼠。
Now, now, I have actually heard this recording, and just an important fact for our human listeners to know before we play this. I should tell you, rat litters, rat litters are about a dozen pups. And this is also important to know-- male rats sometimes eat baby rats. And when they've studied this with lab rats, they found that the males are less likely to eat their own babies. Isn't that right, you guys?
现在，现在，我确实听过这个录音，并且在播放之前对于我们的人类听众来说一个重要的事实。我应该告诉你们，一窝老鼠，一窝老鼠大约有十几只幼鼠。这也是重要的：公鼠有时会吃掉小老鼠。当他们在实验鼠身上研究这个时，他们发现雄性不太可能吃掉它们自己的宝宝。不是吗，你们？
Exactly. Hey, it depends on how much you like the kid.
准确地说。嘿，这取决于你有多喜欢那个孩子。
Look, and it's a cold world, but we have a lot of babies for a reason. All right? You're going to lose a few. You're going to keep a bunch, you know?
看，这是一个冷酷的世界，但我们生这么多宝宝是有原因的。好吧？你会失去几个。你会留下一大堆，你知道的？
You're gonna eat a few.
你会吃掉几个。
OK, so another thing-- this is kind of out there-- scientists have theorized that female rats might choose to mate with lots of males to protect their own pups from being eaten, though as best we can tell, no studies have tested that yet. OK, anything else you guys think we need to say to set this up?
好的，所以另一件事……这有点离谱……科学家推测母鼠可能会选择与很多雄性交配来保护它们自己的幼崽不被吃掉，尽管据我们所知，还没有研究测试过。好了，还有其他你们认为我们需要说来设置这个的东西吗？
No, just roll the tape, all right?
不，只是放磁带，好吗？
Quick warning, this story acknowledges the existence of sex between mammals.
快速警告，这个故事承认哺乳动物之间性行为的存在。
OK, so this is a conversation between rats.
好的，所以这是一段老鼠之间的对话。
Jerry?
杰瑞？
Yeah.
是的。
I have amazing news.
我有惊人的消息。
OK.
好的。
I'm pregnant.
我怀孕了。
No way.
不会吧。
Yeah!
是的！
And you're sure it's mine?
你确定是我的？
Absolutely.
绝对是。
100% sure.
100%确定。
Absolutely.
绝对是。
Because you do, you know, as we all know.
因为你知道，如我们所知。
Yes, no, I did have sex with every other male rat here, but absolutely.
是的，不，我确实和这里的每一只其他公鼠发生过性行为，但绝对是你的。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah.
是的。
Wow.
哇。
So you're not going to eat them.
所以你不会吃掉它们。
Yeah.
是的。
Because they're yours.
因为它们是你的。
Yeah, probably not. I probably won't eat them, yeah. Especially if there's an abundance of food scraps and garbage. If I'm full, I definitely won't eat them. And even if I'm not full, I probably won't eat them.
是的，可能不会。我可能不会吃掉它们，是的。特别是在有大量食物残渣和垃圾的情况下。如果我饱了，我绝对不会吃掉它们。即使我不饱，我也可能不会吃掉它们。
Because they're yours, baby.
因为它们是你的，宝贝。
Yeah. This is the happiest news.
是的。这是最快乐的消息。
I would say that there's a slim chance I would eat more than a couple of these babies. But I'm so excited. Congratulations.
我会说只有极小的机会我会吃掉这些宝宝中的一两个。但我太兴奋了。恭喜你。
I don't want to be a monster here, but Gina had some babies if you're feeling a little peckish.
我不想做个怪物，但吉娜生了一些宝宝，如果你觉得有点饿的话。
That's interesting. Probably I don't-- Gina's babies probably wouldn't hit the spot, you know?
那很有趣。可能我不会……吉娜的宝宝可能不会对口味，你知道吗？
Really?
真的吗？
Gina's so tempestuous. She can get so emotional.
吉娜太火爆了。她变得太情绪化。
Oh, OK, so you know that about Gina really well then.
哦，好的，所以你对吉娜了解得很深嘛。
I'm just saying how I wouldn't want to eat Gina's babies.
我只是在说我为什么不想吃吉娜的宝宝。
Well, look, OK. Are they only Gina's babies, or are they--
好吧，看，好的。它们只是吉娜的宝宝，还是……
I don't know. Are they all little Jesus mice? Unless Gina is having immaculate conception babies, it's definitely hers and someone else.
我不知道。它们是小耶稣鼠吗？除非吉娜是圣母受孕生的宝宝，否则它们绝对是她和别人的。
No, I assumed they were Ralph's.
不，我也以为它们是拉尔夫的。
Yeah, I assumed so, too.
是的，我也以为是。
Well, then why aren't you eating them?
那为什么你不吃它们？
I don't know. Something instinctively-- ooh. Ooh. Listen.
不知道。本能地……噢。噢。听着。
These aren't even yours. There, I said it. These aren't even yours.
它们根本不是你的。看，我说出来了。它们根本不是你的。
That's why I want to eat them so bad. I mean, you have to give me credit. I promise not to eat more than 1/6 of those babies when we both kind of instinctively knew they weren't mine.
这就是为什么我那么想吃掉它们。我的意思是，你得给我点面子。我发誓，当我们两人都本能地知道它们不是我的时候，我保证不会吃超过1/6的宝宝。
Oh, you keep your promises. You really keep your promises.
哦，你遵守诺言。你真的很遵守诺言。
Hey, I'm sorry it didn't work out. You're a great partner. But I guess things bounced the wrong way, and I guess I impregnated Gina. I didn't mean to do it.
嘿，我很抱歉没成功。你是个伟大的伙伴。但我猜事情反弹错了方向，我猜我让吉娜怀孕了。我不是故意的。
[SCOFFS] I can see your nose twitching just when you say her name.
[嘲讽] 只要你说出她的名字，我就能看到你的鼻子在抽搐。
I know.
我知道。
I should have known. Her beady little eyes when she told me she was pregnant. Well, once a rat, always a rat.
我早该知道。她告诉我她怀孕时那双小珠子般的眼睛。好吧，一旦是老鼠，永远是老鼠。
Shout out to our friends, Jerry and Louise.
向我们的朋友杰瑞和路易丝致敬。
Emmanuel Dzotsi produced that story.
伊曼纽尔·佐特西制作了那个故事。
["WE ARE THE RATS" BY MOTO]
["我们是老鼠" - MOTO乐队]
Our program was produced today by Diane Wu and Ike Sriskandarajah.
我们今天的节目由黛安·吴和艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾制作。
The top of the show was produced by Valerie Kipnis.
节目开头由瓦莱丽·基普尼斯制作。
Alaa Mostafa produced our story from Alberta.
阿拉·穆斯塔法制作了我们来自阿尔伯塔的故事。
The people who put together our show today include Phia Bennin, Mike Comite, Aviva Kornfeld, Bethel Habte, Cassie Howley, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Alix Spiegel, Christopher Swetala, and Matt Tierney. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor, David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor, Emanuele Berry.
今天组装我们节目的人包括菲亚·贝宁、迈克·科米特、阿维瓦·科恩菲尔德、伯特利·哈布特、卡西·豪利、塞斯·林德、托宾·洛、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、阿丽莎·希普、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉和马特·蒂尔尼。我们的执行主编是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。高级编辑，大卫·克斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑，伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Special thanks today to--
特别感谢今天——
Rat disease expert Kaylee Byers from the Vancouver Rat Project.
来自温哥华鼠项目的鼠病专家凯莉·拜尔斯。
Robin Nagle.
罗宾·纳格尔。
Ben Miller.
本·米勒。
Ken McCarson.
肯·麦卡森。
Moira Fitzgerald at the Archives at Yale University Library.
耶鲁大学图书馆档案馆的莫伊拉·菲茨杰拉德。
James Edwards.
詹姆斯·爱德华兹。
Kate Smart.
凯特·斯马特。
Lilly Lam.
莉莉·拉姆。
And Curtis Sherrod.
以及柯蒂斯·谢罗德。
And now in real life, you guys are Bashir Salahuddin and Chandra Russell. You guys, let's hear your real voices. Hello.
而在现实生活中，你们是巴希尔·萨拉赫丁和钱德拉·拉塞尔。你们，让我们听听你们真实的声音。你好。
Hello.
你好。
Hey, everybody.
嘿，大家好。
So and people can see you on the TV show South Side on Max. Chandra, you were one of the hosts of the podcast, Unglamorous Truth, that's right?
所以人们可以在Max电视台的电视剧《南区》中看到你们。钱德拉，你是播客《不光彩的真相》的主持人之一，对吧？
Yep, mm-hmm.
是的，嗯哼。
Ow!
噢！
Thank you so much for doing this.
非常感谢你们做这个。
Thank you for having us.
谢谢你们邀请我们。
Thank you for having us. Seriously, man. This is awesome.
谢谢你们邀请我们。说真的，伙计。这太棒了。
Yes.
是的。
The rat improv in our last story was Chris Gethard and Tami Sager.
我们最后一个故事里的老鼠即兴表演是克里斯·格哈德和塔米·萨格。
He's the host of the podcast, Beautiful Anonymous.
他是播客《美丽的匿名》的主持人。
Chris and Tami do an improv show together once a month at the Brooklyn Comedy Collective. Our website, thisamericanlife.org.
克里斯和塔米每个月在布鲁克林喜剧集体一起做一个即兴表演。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
《美国生活》通过PRX，公共广播交易所，传递到公共广播电台。
You guys, let me take the end of the show. Matt and Stowe and Rae, can you turn me into a rat for this last part?
你们，让我来完成节目的最后部分。马特、斯托和雷，你们能在这个最后部分把我变成老鼠吗？
[WARPING EFFECT]
[变形效果]
Wow, everything is so big. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He bought a new leather briefcase this week, but no, he didn't want cowhide, he didn't want snakeskin. He was very specific with the salesperson. They went back and forth.
哇，一切都那么大。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚先生。他这周买了一个新皮公文包，但不，他不想要牛皮，他不想要蛇皮。他对销售员非常挑剔。他们来回商量。
Talk about that real rat.
谈谈那只真正的老鼠。
Real rat.
真正的老鼠。
Real rat, yes.
真正的老鼠，是的。
Real rat rat.
真正的老鼠鼠。
Real real rat rat.
真正的真正的老鼠鼠。
I love the way this sounds. We should do this in a rat voice every week. And maybe we will, when we come back with more stories of This American Life.
我喜欢听起来的感觉。我们每周都应该用老鼠的声音这样做。也许我们会，当我们带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来时。
["WE ARE THE RATS" BY MOTO]
["我们是老鼠" - MOTO乐队]